foreign
morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs as noticed
in the calendar we have several bills
that will be meeting on today an
executive session And discussing but
before that I'd like you to please join
me in the Pledge of Allegiance
pledge allegiance
flag of the United States of America
and to the Republic of which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice of all
thank you everyone
um we have five bills noticed for today
one of them uh Senate Bill 240 there's a
subcommittee working on that bill and
the subcommittee has not finished its
work yet so we will be continuing uh
Senate Bill 240 until next week but um
we we will be discussing the other four
today so I'd like to start off with um
Senate Bill 127 and I understand there's
an amendment representative Shapiro did
you want to speak to that and introduce
that
thank you
sure okay I would um this is actually
representative Weber's Amendment but she
wasn't able to be here today so I'm
going to introduce it
um I moved to adopt amendment
1457h to Senate bill 127.
okay is there a second
representative lay on seconds
representative Shapiro would you like to
speak to your motion
um I I think that um representative
Weber spoke to this
um last week essentially this is a
response to representative Edwards
um concern query about
um how confusing it was about what the
initial fee shall be
um
for providers of methadone
detoxification and maintenance programs
and this clarifies
um the language and and puts into effect
what the actual policy as practiced
currently at DHHS is so that is the
initial fee shall be one thousand
dollars and that's kind of a startup fee
and annually thereafter the fee shall be
eight dollars per client based on the
client annual census of the previous
calendar year so I don't think we're
making any change from what's currently
in statute or currently is practiced but
it just clarifies the language
okay thank you another discussion on the
amendment
I'm seeing no other discussion so I'd
ask to put the Clark quality roll the
movement the emotion is ought to pass on
amendment
1457h to Senate bill 127.
and 202 other members are coming back
just in time
gentlemen you have impeccable senses of
timing
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
representative pelosa
yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Wallner
yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Merchant
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes
representative Lloyd yes
and represent McDonald yes 20-0 okay
great
hey I know of no other amendments to
this bill is there a motion of ought to
pass is amended
if not I can make that motion I'll move
ought to pass as amended is there a
second
uh representative Cannon seconds
any discussion
um in terms of speaking to my motion
um you know I think the department made
a compelling argument I appreciate
attorney Williams and his uh his array
of you know is uh his Entourage that he
brought that morning uh to testify on
the bill they gave us in my view a very
comprehensive
um account of what the bill did what it
needed to do and uh many many uh updates
in terms of statutes and other things
and and that for that reason I'm
inclined to support it
um any other discussion
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman um and I'd like
to thank both the sponsor and the
department for bringing all these
important factors together
um I do want to express my
disappointment that this didn't come did
not come across as six separate bills
sections one two and 16 could have been
one bill that would have been all on one
topic on substance use disorder sections
three and four should have been one bill
on Personal Care Services sections five
six and seven should have been one on
residential care assisted living and
nursing facilities sections eight and
nine deal with beverages entirely
different than the rest that could have
been one bill so we could have better
understood what was happening section
I'll be generous and put section 10 11
and 12 together because it has the Mead
program and snap and they're all social
services and and it's just some basic
revision so that would be the one two
three four fifth small Bill and then
there was a small cleanup one-on reports
I couldn't see any of those hearings
taking very long and those are the sort
of things where we could look at it and
say look this makes a lot of sense any
objections to moving forward with an
executive session right now
I greatly appreciate that this is not
The Tale of Two Cities that we had last
year but still I want to see these bills
come through independently and because
of that I will be voting against this
not because of the content of the
individual sections but because the bet
I believe the best way to legislate is
to allow each of these topics time and
mind space to think about each section
separately
another discussion
saying on I'll ask that the Clark call
the wall the motion the motion is ought
to pass is amended on Senate bill 127.
representative Leon no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King yes
Representative kofault no
representative Boyd no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel yeah
represent peloso yes
representative Cannon
yes
representative Wallner yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Lloyd yes
and representative McDonald yes
15 to 5.
15 to 5 and that'll go on the regular
calendar is that going to be a Minority
Report on that
party report on that okay all about the
majority report
okay
moving on next stop is Senate bill 200.
and I believe there are a couple of
amendments for that uh representative
paulazov
Mr chair I would like to move from
Amendment 2023 15 83 age
okay is there a second
representative Missouri seconds
representative Plaza would you like to
speak to your motion uh yeah yes thank
you Mr chair uh uh I would like to speak
uh in support of amendment uh uh 20 uh
23 15
hs3h
this amendment uh is a a cleaner version
of amendment that I offered uh in the
previous executive session and I'm
thankful to committee members for the
feedback on my previous amendments
specifically
I'm making sure that flu vaccines
stay in place because I got a feedback
from you that flu vaccine is a an
important part of a very popular popular
vaccine and also another Improvement is
that this amendment does not introduce
vaccines that were not called for by
underlying Bill and that we found out
the primary
popular
in administration for kids and this bill
uh is uh not uh dealing with that at the
same time this amendment uh might make
make sure that uh we are putting some
pause in expanding of administration of
covid-19 vaccines because science is
quickly evolving uh on that
initially without the those vaccines are
safe and effective and it took two years
to recognize the connection between
covid-19 vaccines and myocarditis
unfortunately myocarditis is a red
herring I mean
uh myocarditis is only one percent of
severe side effects that those vaccines
are causing uh now last month there was
a recognition of connection between
covid-19 vaccines and stroke which
previously was denied
and there are more more signals that are
coming along
those graphs that I passed to committee
members
you can see that in New Hampshire there
are more for example minus who died
following covid-19 vaccines
administrations and following kovid
itself but also if we look into some New
England populations that are
heavily vaccinated there are
at least a dozen of different uh
uh uh this codes that are through the
roof mostly related to circulation and
blood and while covet itself is a
serious disease that seasonal and might
cause uh things like
pneumonia this respiratory system is
being damaged at the same time we see
that covet vaccines for some reasons are
causing things with circulation for
example you can see a graph with a lymph
node cancer that was a steady
more or less before and it didn't pick
the in 2020 when there was a peak of
people dying from first wave of kovid
but after intellect you using of
vaccines more than 200 percent increase
in this from this kind of cancer and
many of you heard about people
experience
painful symptoms after this vaccines in
their armpits where lymph nodes are
located and usually it's considered to
be not a big deal and it's going away
but as you can see in some cases it
doesn't and it might take months or even
years for it to
to take effect and uh in first quarter
of 2023 it's increased again more than
almost like 400 percent comparing to
what it was before the introduction
introduction of this vaccine that's why
this amendment is asked for a
reasonable pause of two years
with this specific Technologies so we
could investigate it and take a
reasonable precautions and
and that's Amendment thank you thank you
now the discussion representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman
um I will vote against this amendment
for many reasons
um I I appreciate the concerns that
representative had mentioned but I would
um say that that's his opinion and not a
fact that has been borne out in the
literature
um
you have to remember that
the the requests from the optometrist
was specifically in response to covid
and the pandemic and
during my lifetime in many of us here we
have lived through at least eight
different epidemics or pandemics and
we're certainly going to see one again
and therefore I think having
others available to give you know
vaccines shots in arms and the access
for the patients whether it's in the
pharmacy at your primary care office or
in the optometrist office I think is
important
have to also remember that this
messenger RNA technology is not new
messenger RNA was first discovered in
the early 60s and it's been you know
tested and retested and implemented and
used
um and probably since the early 90s the
nanoparticle technology was approved in
1995 and so this is the first true
application of the messenger RNA
technology along with the nanoparticle
you know that was used to introduce the
antigen into the cells so that the T
cells can respond in an emir in
immunological response to the spike
proteins on the covid particle so I I
think it's it's wrong to think about
this as new technology messenger RNA has
been around a long time the work on
messenger RNA in this manner has been
going on for several decades
um
to me to Discount the covid vaccine for
a group of people in response to another
pandemic may come along and that will
probably have a vaccine that uses this
technology is like saying I want to stay
with my rotary phone versus going with a
you know
um uh a 10 series for my iPhone so I I
don't understand discounting the
technology for this purpose alone it has
been around a long time I think it's
been proven to be very effective and you
have to also remember that the FDA gave
its full approval to this over a year
ago and the FDA does continue to monitor
all the signs and symptoms that people
have and in fact when the um
uh Johnson and Johnson vaccine came out
that was actually its authorization was
pulled by the FDA so they do look at the
data they respond to it and they act
accordingly you also have to remember
that over 500 million coveted vaccine
shots have been given worldwide in the
incidence of adverse reactions is de
minimis so for those reasons alone I
will have to vote against this amendment
thank you thank you other discussion
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair I also will be voting
against the amendment I do hear the
concern by the representative
although I don't always share the
concern
um looking at somewhat different than
representative Murphy
I'm a strong believer in standards of
care should be Universal we should have
one standard of care regardless who the
provider is the patient goes to
so in saying that if we're going to
allow all the other providers to give
covert vaccine and
single out optometrist I don't think
it's
really creating a standard of care
across the state of New Hampshire which
would be my goal and number two is that
this is voluntary it's not mandatory so
therefore it's up to the patient I think
I really believe in patience is freedom
of choice and the patient should have
the freedom to choose if they want to to
get the vaccine or not and quite frankly
where they want to get it whether it's
an optometrist a pharmacy or a
physician's office nurse practitioner so
for those reasons I would be voting
against the amendment
thank you other discussion
representative Palazzo I'd like to react
and
thank you representative Murphy uh to
pointing out this that this is a
specific request and relation to covet
pandemic so let's imagine a best case
scenario that
something like this bill would be in
place an optometrist would be using
their Workforce and their good
reputation
to overcome vaccine hesitancy in New
Hampshire and deliver this shorts into
the veins of as many New Hampshire
residences it would be another New
England communities so how many
infections would be stopped and how many
lives would be saved and my point is
it doesn't stop an infection so
infection would be wouldn't be stopped
and from the data that we are seeing uh
I would argue that a couple of hundred
more New Hampshire people would die from
a side effect and we are here inside the
facts a minimal we're healing it's just
a few per million but every member of
this committee knows that side effects
are underreported and also
just uh in in one of the political
caucuses in this committee a little bit
over a dozen people well vaccinated uh
to people publicly came out as having
severe side effects from this vaccine so
it's for me it's not one a few per
million it's a few per dozen so side
effects and death from side effects are
severely under reported and that's why I
uh audio uh question and another
argument we heard last week that it's uh
there was some Under reporting some
some concealment of information from
people but it's a free choice I mean
it's it's a free choice if we all go to
our constituency and we will tell them
that side effects are severely under
reported and that we know that like
several members or substitutes and this
committees had severe side effects of it
but it's not happening when optometrists
will be injecting these vaccines to
people they wouldn't be sharing the
information that this committee knows so
that's why I don't see it as a just a
free market approach because information
is hidden from people thank you
thank you representative Bill King did
you still want to speak no okay any
other discussion
okay seeing none I'll ask that the
clerkalo motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 1583 h
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
Representative copault no
representative Boyd yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosa yes
representative Cannon
representative Wallner no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas no
and representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro
represent a merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no representative
Lloyd no
and represent McDonald no
8 to 12.
okay and I will go on the regular
calendar
oh what's that you wanna that was the
amendment sure is it going to be a
minority wait are you doing a minority
on that uh oh that's right I'm sorry I'm
sorry okay so the amendment fails um
representative Merchant I believe you
have another amendment I do Mr chair
um it's the same one I think I sent out
to everybody electronically but just in
case people don't have it I've made
copies as well
so make a sentence this way
this way
and I'll put some out in the audience
wants to see it
yeah thank you
okay
yeah
okay representative Merchant thank you
so as I said earlier on the other
amendment that was proposed actually do
we have a motion no motion short thank
you I'll make a motion to
um pass house bill
-1568h is there a second
Amendment representative Shapiro seconds
uh would you like to speak to your
motion representative Merchant
thank you Mr
so as I mentioned before I'm a strong
believer in having a standard of care
across all disciplines
um dealing with consistency for the
patient's sake and I worked with
representative Cushman on this as well
she brought it up during the hearing
that the requirements for a an
optometrist to give the vaccine
is somewhat different than the
requirements for the pharmacist to get
the vaccine so what we did collectively
was go back and look at the RSA for the
pharmacist and basically at that point
in time take the same requirements that
they are required to have and insert
those requirements into this statute
and the requirements are
they hold a current license to practice
which is understandable they complete
the training course they have a million
dollars in liability insurance a waiver
for this specifically
they hold it active certification of
pulmonary cardio basic cardiopulmonary
resuscitation and they provide to the
board of Optometry
the documentation they have all of this
in place before they're actually
condemnonized
so I think it's a logical thing to do is
that if you want to protect the patient
because you want training
if something does go wrong it does you
want to be sure that there's liability
insurance to cover the event if it does
and you also want to be sure that
they're providing some sort of oversight
board in this case the board of
Optometry that they have in fact met all
those requirements before they can
actually get the immunization so that's
reason why I'm bringing this forth to
the committee
um so that's my my comments thank you of
the discussion
any other discussion representative
Nagel
um
I'm not that familiar with Optometry but
a million dollars is a lot of liability
insurance why was that number picked I'm
just curious
why yeah because it's a time in which
the RSA when was going through the
legislative body that's what was great
too thanks
that is
representative Murphy did you have your
hand up yeah thank you um uh just a
question to representative Merchant and
I I did put this in an email to him
because I just wanted to get the answer
is that
you mentioned using diphenhydramine as
well as epinephrine and equivalent
medications would given that the
patients that have any anaphylaxis
reaction also have pulmonary issues you
know and are treated sometimes with
oxygen or in the hill like albuterol
would it be better in your mind to have
something more Broad in its terminology
like medical management and Pulmonary
support as
um uh per CPI protocols
there's a good question representative
Murphy I wrestled with that because
in one sense yes it would but in the
other sense no because when you get to
that level of care
I think the training you need is going
to be beyond what they're going to
receive in the training of giving the
shots if to give an epinephrine
injection is one thing start giving the
patient albuterol
oxygen and so forth It's probably time
to call the EMT
my follow-up I would agree and I
appreciate the response I was just
thinking before the EMTs get there would
they be better off serve to have oxygen
available in any other medications as
per CPR protocol that's all thank you
thank you
other discussion
seeing none
okay the motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 1568 h
representative Leon yeah
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative colfault yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosa yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Wallner yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
represent a merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
represent Palmer yes
representative Lloyd yes
representative McDonald yes
Amendment passes 20-0
okay thank you
I know of no other amendments do I have
a motion about to pass as amended make a
motion not the passes amended okay is
there a second
representative Palmer seconds any
discussion on the motion
seeing representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman
um I I do want to thank representative
Murphy for his point about the potential
dangers that can happen once you start
and start having these these different
issues
um I know that there there's the medical
Freedom side of the argument here saying
that as long as you have the adequate
training it makes sense to be able to
provide these vaccines there's the
question too about how that impacts the
competitiveness of different practices
so
um I I see that there can be multiple
viewpoints on this about how much of a
net positive it is I know that I'll be
supporting this but I'm not sure you
know that's one of these where it needs
to be left up to our individual
conscience to see if we think that the
benefits outweigh the risks
uh representative
thank you Mr chair uh
uh I'm really thankful for amendments
that uh is passed but I still will be
voting against this bill I think that
optometrists need to be focused uh on
the care of their patients eyes instead
of doing vaccines and vaccines will be a
distraction for the main function uh
optometrists typically do not listen to
patients had they typically do not take
patients blood pressure
and they typically do not have a handle
of the patient's full medical history
optometrists will be opening themselves
to liability with this new
responsibilities that they will have and
I I believe that there's no issues like
we don't see like a line of people
asking abdominal lists and seeking for
vaccines
so for this reasons I think it's not
needed and it's opening for
dangerous situations especially that it
touches
such I believe harmful medications as
covid-19 vaccines
thank you another discussion
representative Bill King
thank you Mr chair and I I also will not
be supporting this bill overall even
though the um the amendment was a was a
good attempt uh unfortunately there's
more of um uh looking out for the small
optometrists they have big concerns
about this and so I'm just looking out
for the the little guys that's my that's
thank you of the discussion
so ignore the discussion I'll ask the
clear call the wall the motion is ought
to pass is amended on SB 200.
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman
no
representative Bill King no
representative kofault yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel no
Representative pelosa no
representative Cannon yes
representative Wallner yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer no
no representative Lloyd yes
and representative McDonald yes
14-6 it passes
okay it'll go on the regular calendar
I'm assuming there'll be a Minority
Report on this
you already representative Palazzo do
you want to do The Minority Report on
this or
who's doing the majority report
okay
yes
can I do my another Channel but uh
uh what to pass with the amendment that
failed or like uh
feels like yeah
okay Mr chair I'll write the majority
report thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman um I I might recommend that if
you support you since you supported the
committee Amendment as well to have a
separate Amendment drafted that includes
both the committee and that I'm not sure
what the right procedure would be but
let's I just want to make sure we don't
accidentally get rid of those important
changes so we'll get guidance to figure
out the right Amendment
okay many other comments before we move
on okay thank you next up is uh Senate
Bill 239
and do I have a motion on that
actually there's several amendments so
I'm not sure who wants to go first
thank you
yeah most of it you have most of them
representative Nagel so yeah
I don't know you did have four
what happened to the fourth one
um
microphone microphone
all right I should know this by now but
I'm gonna do it wrong um I want to move
Amendment
2023-1581h on
Senate Bill 239 for consideration
is there a second
representative Leon seconds would you
like to speak to your motion
representative Google
um
one of the local TV stations yesterday
unwittingly made my case for this motion
yesterday
um my concern about this bill has been
the rights of people in pain and and
that they not become stigmatized and
harmed by this kind of Bill the
terminology that was being asked to
change
um I thought put them at risk and
yesterday on um
the television station when they were
talking about
um
um the opioid crisis they just showed
spill bottles of pills as their example
and that bothers me a lot so I thought
that this became even more important
because that stigmatized our patients
um what we did on it's on page one
um under 12j-1
um it adds the following language
um that nothing in rsa12j should be
construed to limit care of chronic pain
and hospice and palliative care patients
including the term misuse which shall be
utilized as independent to broaden the
scope of work across the substance use
Continuum of Care
my purpose in this amendment was to
basically preserve their rights
any discussion
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Nagel for bringing this
very important amendment I think that
it's absolutely crucial that when
somebody is fighting for their life we
provide them the appropriate tools for
pain management and worry about
addiction after we save their life first
and also when you're in that much pain
addictions a lot less of an option a lot
less likely than when you are in a
different scenario so um this has my
full support and my thanks
of the discussion representative
nadarapam
I worked for three years at a hospice
house and I remember seeing patients
coming in in tremendous pain because
their primary care doctor or cancer
doctors were afraid to give them like
enough medication and once you're in
hospice I think you know a good hospice
they palliate palliate their pain and I
would see these same patients who had
come in on a gurney like awful
three days later they're playing cards
in the living room
so I mean it's so important that um
the fear of addiction is inappropriate
in a hospice setting and that it's so
wonderful When people's pain can be
palliated
it's Humane so thank you
representative land thank you Mr
chairman I think that I will actually
expand a little bit on this um the
palliative care also isn't necessarily
end of life
if I can talk to a personal reason why
I'm supporting this my mother-in-law
developed a bed sore and she had one
that was grapefruit sized and when she
was sent to a hospital for wound care
and pain treatment she was given
Tramadol
pretty much all of our last words were
ten ten ten for pain because they
refused to get a consult in order to
actually appropriately manage her pain
and by not managing that pain her body
was so busy dealing with that pain it
was unable to fight off the infection
and the assault on her bodily Integrity
had she had pain management she still
might not have survived but she would
have had a Fighting Chance when she got
transferred to another hospital that
actually took pain as a Vital sign and
took pain as an important thing
she relaxed and she finally knew that
she was getting help if this amendment
if this it has one small part to keep
other people from going through that
torture while trying to fight for their
lives then we've done good things this
year
representative Nagel
thank you that was wonderful
um I also want to expand this discussion
just to say that for the record and
again I was very concerned and upset
about the public portrayal of the
patients I represent on a local
television station yesterday but roughly
66 million people in the United States
suffer from chronic pain 20 million have
what we call high impact chronic pain we
estimate 15 million of those people who
do not benefit from other therapies can
benefit from long-term opioid therapy
and the public policy response to the
opioid crisis which addresses fewer than
2 million people with opioid use
disorders sixty percent of whom had a
prior substance used as sort of the
predated their opioid use disorder
is basically served to harm them
creating a public policy or Public
Health crisis that we refer to as opioid
refugees who are not getting care that
they need getting denied access to
treatment that had worked and resulting
in unnecessary suicide unnecessary going
to the street to treat their own
medication or suffering needlessly and I
think that there needs need to be
recognized too and that was the other
reason that this was important
another discussion representative
Merchant
it's more Uncommon I wanted to thank
Crimson Nagel
one of the things that caught my
attention was the fact on line four and
five
is the word Other Drug which basically
implies alcohol itself is a drug
so I wanted to say thank you for that
and recognizing that we have alcohol as
a drug and not looking at it as a
non-drug
of the discussion
I'm seeing no other discussion last at
the Clark Hollow oil motion is ought to
pass on Amendment 1581 h
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosa yes
representative Cannon yes
representative walner yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Lloyd yes
representative McDonald yes
20-0 passes 20-0
okay
um and I believe you have another
amendment representative Nagel
oh yeah
[Music]
okay
A Boy Scout and I'm prepared thank you
no treatment
um I would like to move that Amendment
2023-1505 H to SB 239b on pass thank you
is there an amen a second
representative Missouri seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
sure
um if one turns to page five on the bill
um at the bottom on line 25 under
continuing medical education
um
um Senator Waters and I actually worked
on this together he had listed
um a recommendation
um for doctors
um for CME for basically uh substance
use
um I had pointed out to him that that
actually already existed in
um in medical rules so all we did was we
struck his language and we put the
existing language
um from uh the boredom at uh yeah the
board of medicine's rules which
basically says all licensees are
required to register with the all
licensees required to register with a
controlled drug prescription health and
safety program shall complete three
credit hours of approved online uh
continuing education or pass an online
examination in the area of pain
management or addiction disorders
um that is actually more stringent
requirement than what he had written um
and it's we think it's important
I should add one more thing
um the average doctor gets um in his
training or her training seven hours of
training and Pain Management the average
veterinarian actually gets substantially
more than that um the average doctor
gets very little if any training and
addiction medicine so I don't know about
veterinarians on addiction but anyways
um we we do believe that that's a huge
hole in medical education and this is a
way to um to fill that hole and that's
why that language was uncertain in the
state rules sure representative Shapiro
and then representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair
um thank you for bringing this amendment
and I'm just curious
[Music]
um
why it doesn't say and addiction
disorders as opposed to oral addiction
disorders
um the way it's listed right now is a
doctor can use that three hours for
either
so in other words like each it has to be
done every two year cycle so one cycle I
can do one the reality is is pretty much
every exercise we do includes both
within it but you can do either or
representative Merchant and
representative Murphy thank you Mr chair
and also thank you representative Nagel
for bringing us forth
it's more of a procedural issue the way
this is written
and I'd like to someone else who's more
involved with the process here this is
in the RSA governing Physicians and
surgeons So when you say all licensees I
think I know what's implied
however because it's in the RSA chapter
for Physicians and surgeons it's only
for those who are licensed by the Board
of Medicine it would not include people
from the board of dentistry people from
the board of
natural past people from the boards at
the board so I just want to bring that
to people's attention to someone to
clarify that to me to be helpful
that is a really important point and I
spent about two hours last night at a
restaurant scrolling through every rule
in New Hampshire to figure this out so
um
and I think that's an important thing
and it needs to be included it turns out
that dentists actually have in their
rules they do have pretty much the same
language doctors do
um
um for their requirement
um so it's in rules now
um I I actually can my wife's an MP so
we talked about this last night I
there's no place in the NP rules that
actually specifies that they need to do
this however so I asked I know she has
to get three hours so I asked where does
that come from she said it's from the
DEA registration requires that you do
that
that I didn't have time to look into but
they're important things that should be
added at some point I'm not totally sure
if this is the right place to do that
um but I think we have a lot of work
with those boards to make sure those
things are addressed
the follow-up just for clarity so you're
through this amendment looking strictly
at Physicians and surgeons and PAs this
would not include nurse practitioners
dentists in Southworth I'm not sure it
includes Pas either for that matter it's
it is an important addition and we
certainly could work on that if you want
I think it's a it's important addition
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman I and maybe this
was answered by representative Nagel but
I'm trying to clarify why we need the
language in the first place
um
as we all as you know we obviously have
to
um have three hours of
uh CME credits um every two years you
have to get your license renewed you
have to have a hundred hours of CME
credits 40 of which have to be category
one and of that forty three have to be
for pain management in addiction so we
already have that in statue in fact the
statue is RSA 318-b colon 40. so one of
my questions was why do we need to have
that language into this step into this
bill right now
um and also in response to your comment
about you know how many hours uh the
Vets have to have versus The Physicians
the DEA just came out with a new
one-time
ruling that all Physicians have to have
a one-time eight-hour course in
addiction and pain control so that was
effective as of December of last year so
um I guess my question was the need for
having this language if it's already
written in Statue elsewhere
I'll look through this statute again I
wasn't aware it existed in statute just
in rules I I be honest with you I had
really mixed feelings about this being
in statute because it is clearly in
rules and it's in rules for all three
boards right now right yeah I mean is it
absolutely necessary that's the way it
was brought to us and I'm not sure I can
make a convincing argument for that
on the discussion your representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair
representative representative Murphy um
the DEA requirement that's strictly for
Physicians or anyone who has the ability
to write a prescription for an opiate I
believe it's for anybody that can write
for um uh the medication
thank you and it's three hours
um out of the 40 CME credits or category
one but like I said there there's a new
um uh stat new rule that came out
through the DEA as of December of this
past year that requires a one-time
eight-hour course in opioid in pain
management and again that's for all
providers yes I believe so
representative Nagel yeah that's a
really important point and the other
thing we always have to remember too is
that criteria that if you're registered
with the Dei you need to do that if
you're not registered with a DEA like
some nurse practitioners are not
the minute you put this in statute then
all of them have to do it even if they
don't provide any addiction or pain
services so that probably doesn't make
any sense so that's why my wife said
that that was not unnecessary for NPS
of the discussion
any other discussion
seeing none I'll ask Clark to call the
roll uh the motion is ought to pass on
Amendment
1505h but uh Senate Bill 239
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
Boyd yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
Representative peloso no
representative Cannon
representative Wallner no
representative McKay
Representative fredis no
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro
no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer yes
representative Lloyd no
the tiebreaker to representative
McDonald yes
11 to 9 the amendment passes
okay
uh by the way we need a second we need
to find out who made the second on the
First Amendment
first on I'd be on the second on that
one okay thank you I have another one
okay representative Nagel still has some
amendments to go so fantastic okay
um
so just for the record I had never done
an amendment before today so I'm kind of
making up making up a lost time yeah
exactly
um so this is I would like to move
um Amendment
2023-161 h on Senate Bill 239 sorry what
was that number again uh
2023-1618 H okay one eight H okay thank
you
um is ought to pass
and is there a second
second representative Merchant seconds
um you may speak to your motion so when
this again getting back to what I said
with the First Amendment one of my big
concerns with this bill was that there
were a lot of terms being used that were
not being defined
um and so I looked through statutes and
found out that none of them were defined
in statute either so we kind of felt a
number of us that these holes needed to
be filled so there were
um basically misuse was used to
substitute for the word um abuse and
what I found interesting about that word
was that it was extremely hard to find a
definition of what that actually meant
um and I looked at Nida I looked at
samhsa I looked everywhere so um there's
a clear definition for that as it
applies to prescription drugs but not to
drugs in general so if we were going to
use that broad change I thought that
that really needed to be defined the
other term of importance was harm
reduction
um that we there is a pretty pretty good
overview of that in the governor's
commission report on Alcohol and Other
Drugs
um and if anybody is wants to can refer
to that but um we basically did for that
and this is the Senators Edition
um Senator waters on um
he took the definition from samhsa which
is fairly consistent with what the
governor said and the reason why all
these are important again is that is the
opioid abatement Commission and the
governor's commission start to work
better together which we think is really
important it would be really helpful to
have nomenclature that's that we can use
consistent consistently with each other
the other issue is that harm reduction
is becoming a bigger and bigger issue
and um and in Senator rosenwald's
earlier bill that we saw that was a big
part of that bill so we really needed to
find what we were talking about
um with that as a background
um I chose to look at prescription drugs
and this is going to be an addendum at
the end of the bill so it's not
replacing any language
um
um there were two things there was
misuse of prescription drugs and I'm I'm
hopefully missed the uh
yes I'm sorry I know she did include
both so the first thing was Miss I I
separated drug misuse and misuse of
prescription drugs misuse of
prescription drugs is a well-defined
thing in samhsa's night is
um uh criteria means taking a medicine
in a medication and manner or dose other
than prescribed it's a very broad topic
abuse is a very minor or small part of
that for example if I'm prescribed one
Percocet every four hours and I take it
one every two hours and that would be
classified as misuse
if I shoot up heroin or that oxycodone
that would be considered abuse
um that's why the difference is
important drug misuse is a separate
thing that we worked on together again
looking at samsa Nida background drug
misuse refers to the use of a substance
for a purpose that is not consistent
with legal or medical guidelines
um
the other one was harm reduction and
that's in section five
um and
really basically this is very similar to
the governor's definition it's harm
reduction shall mean an approach that
emphasized engaging directly with people
who already used
drugs to prevent overdose and infectious
disease Transmissions improve the
physical mental and social well-being of
those served offering low threshold
options for accessing substance use
disorder and other health care services
and promoting a philosophy of Hope and
healing by utilizing those with lived
experience of recovery in the management
of harm reduction
stigmatization was an important issue
that's not mentioned right in that it's
implied in those the governor's overview
if I can do that there's one two three
four five six points to it the first one
is do we enhance harm capacity of harm
reduction programs ensure the
availability of opioid reversal
education naloxone things like that and
availability expand access to drug
checking Services throughout the state
expand the utilization of harm reduction
strategies through Street Outreach
drop-in centers peer support services
critical time intervention programs
develop and implement strategies to
reduce the stigma again regarding harm
reduction services
I have a lot of patients that are
stigmatized on methadone that's another
long story expand engagement of Health
Care Providers and this is where the
education comes and expand engagement of
Health Care Providers and health systems
and providing harm reduction education
materials and services
so that's why those things were added
the discussion yes it's not
representative Murphy
excuse me need some water yeah um thank
you thank you thank you very much uh my
question is representative Nagel I agree
with all the wording that is in your
Amendment my question is whether it's
simply broad enough
um and regardless of the governor's
commission you know definition of not if
we put into statute a harm reduction
definition and it's too narrow does that
narrow the scope of potential you know
um modalities of treatment down the road
um would it be better in your mind to
Simply refer harm reduction to the samsa
definition for those not familiar with
Samsung is um Substance Abuse and Mental
Health Services Administration that was
actually established by the department
of U.S department of HHS in 1990
something
um but they have in their website a very
broad definition including things like
education condom use a the testing and
that sort of thing and so my question is
would we be better served having a
reference to the samsa definition so
that it includes all the various you
know treatment modalities in education
that goes along with it
yes okay
no I agree I I I personally think
broader is better
that's my opinion
representative Merchant
thank you reps of Nagel thank you for
the amendment
um
on line six
you talk about misuse of prescription
drugs however we go back and look at the
amendment we first passed
it talks about
Alcohol and Other Drug misuse
so my concern is that we're
sort of have a conflict between the two
definitions
um and what I'm trying to get to is that
you could have misuse of alcohol as well
as drugs so it doesn't always have to be
a prescription drug per se could be
something that's an alcohol with it so
it also means taking a medication versus
using a drug so I'm just concerned that
this definition conflicts with the other
one we just passed so that's a really
important point and I'm not happy seeing
how this was written up because it's not
the way I presented it the way it was
presented is those were two separate
definitions
um in other words I agree totally with
everything you just said that drug use
of substances is a separate issue from
drug use of prescription drugs and
they're separate definitions and they
were intended to be that way in what
this amendment was should we yeah
go ahead sure go ahead would you be
amenable to sending something down to
OLS and try to get this changed as
quickly as possible thank you sorry was
one of them last night just saw for the
first time
representative plazov
so I have a comment and question a
comments that uh I don't see a problem
with previous Amendment because if
previously we defined this Alcohol and
Other Drugs it means that alcohol is
also drugs so I think there's no
conflict here
the issue is the word prescription
you don't need a prescription for
alcohol
that's that's what the conflict I think
arises
and uh go ahead so my follow-up question
is uh
somebody or opposite of the first
question that my concern
would be if this definition is too broad
it can open uh
provide this to new liabilities and open
us to new expenses
so I wonder what committee members think
about
if the definitions which I I see quite
broad like home reduction like uh
um it includes several broad topics here
uh so my question would be uh with this
definitions that are still pretty Broad
do you see uh it opening us to new
liabilities opening providers to new
liabilities opening state to new
expenditures
yeah
I don't personally see a liability issue
I I maybe can you ask that question
again I'm going to make sure I
understand it better
I'm sorry I missed a lot of what you
said in the beginning go ahead
representative Palazzo
um
the question uh
yeah basically uh
do you see this definitions
as uh competit to not having definitions
and underlying bills and by broadening
providers and the state for new
expenditure just to try to address
those brought the definitions of
the drug misuse of hand reductions so
yeah as far as misuse of drugs those are
very well defined things and the real
the reason I was concerned
was that some abuse is basically called
self-medication and we need to be really
careful about how we we Define what
we're talking about so for example
um people like to quote 12 million
incidences of um of opioid or I think
it's opioid misuse a year that is an
incredibly deceptive number when one
considers 70 of those are actually
people self-medicating like for example
you know we hear this every day a
patient gets a prescription for Tylenol
with codeine or Vicodin or something for
procedure they leave it in their case
they get severe pain their doctor won't
see them for three months they're in
agony and they say fine I'm going to
take that because I got it
that's called common sense to me
personally um but but that's
characterized as misuse so by by
defining these things better and we have
a clear abuse a definition of abuse
that's already in statute we don't have
a definition of misuse and I thought
that it was important that that actually
be defined the reason why you separate
um
um prescription drugs from
non-prescription drugs is that and I
thought that this was also important is
because misuse of a non-prescription
drugs very different like for example
now cannabis is a is a non-prescription
drug um and most people that are using
are actually self-medicating but it's a
totally different concept so I thought
it was important to bring those things
to light rather than just throw this
term misuse that can be used for almost
anything and that was my concern as they
said well this is best practice and I
said well what does it actually mean so
we tried to figure out what they meant
by best practice rather than just
leaving some nebulous term out there as
far as harm reduction is concerned
um I've done a lot of work with samhsa
over the last 15 years they're really
smart people I trust they've been
working on these issues for a very long
period of time if you look at the
governor's oversight or Governor's
program that they've developed it's
pretty much straight from samhsa
guidelines so I mean that I I think that
that
there's a little bit of trust involved
in here but I think I trust them to
Define what the term means
um
anyways I'll leave it at that
representative profile
uh thank you Mr chairman so just uh two
two comments one regarding the the
broadness or narrowness of the
definition of of harm reduction uh my
concern with the original bill is that
the the definition essentially doesn't
exist so it's so broad you could drive a
truck through it
um for what it's worth I think that the
the definition of harm reduction offered
here is still too broad
um so we're going to have different
opinions on that sometimes if uh if if
some are against it and some are for it
you then you probably hit the mark
um the the
um
the other comment I'll make is has to do
with references to external
organizations
um I'm opposed to them
um
we do this a lot in statute and in rules
that we are referencing what some other
body says determines uh puts out as a
statement
um
and those things can change so when
those things change our laws change
without the people's Representatives
having a single thing to say about it so
um without speaking to
you know whether or not we should trust
samhsa they sound like a good
organization I would vigorously oppose
anything that that included an external
reference and sort of left to someone
else to to
create that definition and uh
potentially change it down the road
did you want to respond yeah I really
appreciate it representative Shapiro I
totally appreciate that and um that's
why I didn't just accept the samhsa
definition because that's what was
provided to me
um I tried to look through
again this is an issue of best practices
in the field so what I tried to do is
look through as many sites of of
organizations and other states what do
people are saying to try to come up with
a definition and I think your earliest
comment made the most sense is that it's
a pretty nebulous comment concept to
Define so
I appreciate that representative Shapiro
I just got a message that the Department
of Health and Human Services would like
to chime in on this issue that they have
some concerns okay
um
it was oh Higgins
see if I could provide any Clarity in
this um these definitions at all so one
of the the pieces this is kind of a
situation where the language is catching
up to the best practice in the field so
as representative Nagel had talked about
the definition of misuse really is
around prescription misuse and so as you
dig into what does that misuse mean it
is broader and and really speaks to
alcohol and tobacco and Other Drugs
right and so we're trying to get to a
place where it's comprehensive where we
can both research and fund the full
Continuum of Care including prevention
right and get Upstream from these issues
and so that's the purpose and intent of
the language change as well as the piece
I spoke about in my testimony and our
hearing
um of the word abuse having some
negative connotation and continuing to
perpetuate stigma and so that's the
purpose of using of using misuse the
definition in the second line of the
amendment that says drug misuse refers
to the use of a substance for a purpose
best that's not consistent with legal or
medical guidelines I believe covers the
misuse of prescription drugs because
that would be outside of medical
guidelines so then that may keep it
broad enough to not have that first to
not have that first sentence which I
think is covered by the second the other
thing that you could do is that
substance use broadly is well defined
already and refers to the use of
selected substances including alcohol
tobacco products drugs inhalants and
other substances that could be consumed
um with possible dependence or
detrimental effects that's the substance
use definition and you could go that
direction and use a well-defined sort of
definition that keeps it broad moves
away from the stigmatizing language so
it still has the same intent
okay representative co-falt and
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman so uh one other
comment I wanted to make was uh with
respect to representative Murphy's
statement about concerns that a narrow
death a too narrow definition of harm
reduction would
close off the path to certain treatment
and one of the things that came up in
the hearing because I asked specifically
about Methadone in my research
I had seen methadone
classified in some by some medical
experts as
harm reduction and so I asked about it
and the answer we heard
from the witness was
no I would classify that as treatment so
I guess that that's another thing that
concerns me here is do we have Clarity
on what is harm reduction versus what is
treatment because I don't see any
definition of harm reduction would would
shut off Avenues to treatment but it it
it sort of brings more light to the the
concern that the definitions are are
poor all around and that that is my
general concern with the bill
can I get your opinion on the harm
reduction definition yes so I think that
harm reduction is just any kind of
Public Health intervention that would
reduce harm that's why it feels like
that is so broad but but treatment is
clearly defined and treatment is also
harm reduction right it's under the
umbrella of because because receiving
treatment reduces harm reduces fatality
it is both
that's fair representative Merchant you
had a hand up earlier it was going back
to the
initial part lines four through six I'm
sorry six through uh eight so if we want
to continue with the discussion about
harm reduction before we move on or sure
okay the issue I again trying to board
Smith it here
what are your thoughts on reading misuse
of drugs including alcohol
means using the substance in a manner or
dose
for a purpose that is not consistent
with legal or medical guidelines
I think that makes sense to me
thank you
representative Nagel
um
can I bring up like a conflict here so
I I on purpose most medicine is the
practice of making Simplicity out of
complexity my life is making the
practice of complexity out of simplicity
so a lot in the world that I live in
there's not a lot of easily defined
terms and that creates a conflict when
you bring it into a legal or legislative
thing and we're trying to Define
extremely complex issues with simple
language and I I think it's an
interesting dilemma
um
I I really like the definition that we
came up with I think that that works the
best
um
anyways as far as the other issue the
prescription it's really important to me
personally to differentiate between
prescription and other substances I mean
to me personally in my world it's very
important to differentiate between those
two and that's why I chose to do it
I will leave it up to your decision as
to whether you want to do that or not
but and we can talk more about this um
but it's it's it's an important
differentiation again for protecting the
rights of the people that I represent so
anything else with the Department
representative Leon thank you Mr Sherman
and thank you for being here
um I hear that you have a very broad
definition of harm reduction and you
want to have every tool available how
critical is the section that allows for
use of the general funds to that program
in order to increase your harm reduction
services
there it is the the ability to fund our
harm reduction right now is it does
affect whether or not those are
sustainable programs so it in places
where the the federal government has
opened up available funding sources we
just need the ability to do that in New
Hampshire to use those federal funds
potentially the scope of this
legislation just makes that allowable
but there is not a particular funding
source we would then begin using for
those fun for those programs immediately
and then thank you as a follow-up um it
seems that this whole program
um especially with that Focus towards
the the legal or medical differences
um how does this work
um I I guess when you're looking at harm
reduction and reducing the harm about
everything except for convictions for
having one of these substances I guess
I'm trying to figure out how you weigh
um all these other mitigation factors
and keep the criminality as one of those
crucial components when that
stigmatization of the criminality is one
of the things that leads to some of
those negative outcomes
this part piece of the statue is around
the governor's commission which does
include the the commission makeup itself
includes the Department of Justice and
Corrections and so they do work closely
on how we also change other pieces of of
Statute around the criminality of
substance use
um and but what this P but what they're
the funding piece around the governor's
commission does is specifically funding
for the harm reduction of substance use
in the space around public health and
and you know prevention treatment and
recovery and not within the the legal
piece around the criminality of
substance illicit substance use but it
does include treatment things like
treatment prevention and Recovery
supports for folks who have been
involved in the criminal justice system
exiting incarceration is a particular
focus of the of samhsa and the CDC
because of the real increase rates of
Overdose post incarceration
thank you
anything else with the Department yes
representative Nagel you're way smarter
about this than me so I I wanted it I'm
curious as I read this I was
you know there's a two-part to this bill
there's the governor's commission
there's the opioid abatement commission
and it seemed to me that by that
language that um you know eliminated
certain part allowed State funds to be
used
would that allow opioid abatement funds
to be used for these purposes that it's
not able to use now that's how I read it
but I may be wrong
the opioid abatement funds don't I don't
sit in the state
General funds I'm trying to think of
exactly where they are sort of in the
budget but it could potentially open up
the the use of that funding source
I think the idea is to make sure that we
have access to all of those all of the
funding sources if in fact there there
is that need and application with the
opioid abatement funds people apply for
the funding and so if there was that
need and then the um it may be a funding
source that we can't that can do
something we can't do elsewhere right so
we have several restrictions especially
our federal funding sources all come
with specific restrictions and the
opioid abatement funds the best thing we
can do for New Hampshire is look at all
of our funding sources comprehensively
and identify where our current funding
sources have gaps and use the opioid
abatement funds to plug those gaps yeah
thanks
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman and just thank you
for your testimony I'm not sure
what part of the big department you
represent uh and uh if you could help us
because this is a complex
issue and I think you were sent up to
clarify it but I don't know who you
represent
I'm sorry I am a policy analyst and the
legislative liaison for the division for
Behavioral Health within the department
Health and Human Services
other discussion
anything else for the Department
seeing none okay thank you very much
thank you
so where do we stand with this amendment
is it going back to OLS or are we
proceeding with a vote or I would think
proceed with a vote no oh
um
okay we're borrowing your motion to
ought to pass
and who is the second I was second I
would draw okay
all right so we'll uh we'll wait for a
new Amendment uh addressing some of
these concerns that were expressed we
have another amendment
um that's all you have representative
Nagel right
and representative Leon has one uh thank
you Mr chairman
um I'd move that we adopt um Amendment
2023-1621h for Senate Bill 239 and I'll
pass that around
Mr chairman uh yes I'll second that
motion okay thank you
uh representative land do you want to
speak to your motion uh thank you Mr
chairman
um I think that this bill tackles a lot
of different issues and I think we have
one thing that's definitely very
critical making sure that we're able to
have the doorways program making sure
that we're able to have drug checking
and that we're able to get out on the
street and do these quantifiable known
harm reduction efforts
um this is an area where I I think I
appreciate wanting to extend all of this
harm reduction but I still remain very
very uncomfortable by this Broad and
nebulous definition of
um any public health intervention that
would reduce harm because there's a lot
that can go into that I especially am
nervous with that with Section 13 which
um we already in statute had the ability
to use any federal funds that
um were on that we had the ability to
administer and or disperse Federal and
other funds to syringe service programs
authorized under this section the
section that part that's being struck in
13 is the prohibition of use of state
general funds so in this bill we both
have the ability to use the opioid
abatement trust fund and state general
funds for a all of the above type
solution
um
I want to tackle this program but I'd
rather do it in steps as opposed to
jumping off of a cliff and hoping my
parachute was packed that's actually one
of these things
um
that's another topic I'm going to get
into with this um so if you go to come
to the bill I'll let you know which ones
I'm looking to remove
um well I guess which ones I'm looking
to keep I think it's very important to
keep the president of the New Hampshire
Association if she's the chiefs of
police or designee on the commission
um
then we have section eight uh
sorry first page line 17
through
19 is section two so that would stay
and that's the one that puts the
association achieves the police this
would remove the broad language
um that's changing that definition from
abuse to misuse that clearly is a
challenge to Define and the harm
reduction which is also a challenge to
Define that rather than trying to defend
Define that today and then send it back
just for a community of conference as
opposed to trying to have a larger
Dialogue on how to best Define these
terms quite frankly it would kick the
can down the road a little bit there but
I'm not sure that we're going to get to
agreement on definitions of misuse or
harm reduction so my offer here was to
remove those sections so that this whole
bill and the ver the good that can come
from it isn't lost in that debate over
definitions so then we would keep the
association of chiefs of police on the
commission
um
and then in section three the
organization of the task force including
prevention and harm reduction is that
blank check it's that full definition
that either is the one that people view
as too narrow or it's the one where it's
any public health intervention
um I think that that loses focus when
you're looking at everything and I'm not
comfortable with that and with that
language this bill doesn't have my
support so in order to try and reach
compromise my Amendment removes that
section
similarly in section four the task force
it has that misuse and harm reduction in
there
um as we roll into page two section five
has that harm reduction and misuse in
there
um
so not being comfortable with the
definitions not being confident that we
will find one that I'm that I'm willing
to accept I think that it's better to
remove those sections then the meetings
and reports also use that same language
so we get into page three
page seven as well sorry section seven
also has the misuse and harm reduction
so page three
all right we're looking at a lot of
bolded and italic misuse and harm
reduction as we scroll through this and
I apologize that I'm going quickly I'm
just trying to figure out that right
balance of speed and and slowness
now on page three line 19.
I
recognize that there's some challenges
around the definition of harm reduction
but including some discussion of harm
reduction along with two or even
programs I figure as a way to get things
started and start discussing this in
these reports to to not have a blank
check to go Whole Hog on these but that
gets that discussion moving into that
task force by speaking about the
potential of harm reduction in the
report for eight I'm a little ambivalent
on including that I probably if I were
to draft this again would take that
section 8 out but I'm trying to
compromise and get to something where we
can get agreement so that's why I kept
that part with the harm reduction
and now we get to what I think is very
very important about this bill
section 9 on P online 21 of Page Three
is when we get in to the syringe service
program funding
um it does say including harm prevention
supplies so once again we're back to my
definition but I'm trying to find
something that we can do to help people
with these challenges
um so this would allow funding from the
opioid abatement funds for the syringe
service supplies which I think is a
reasonable use of those funds and then
section 10 starting at line 26 on line
three is the doorways program the
substance use disorder access points
I think that that's done a lot of good I
don't want to lose that over the
confusion of definitions
moving to page that stays in moving to
page four section 11 would stay in
that's the part that's including
criminal justice in the collaboration
around the servant and orange service
programs
section 12 which is Consulting and
informing with Municipal law enforcement
agencies concerning the syringe service
programs and harm reduction activities
that would stay in that's important
collaboration
section 13 however would come out that
is the one that removes the prohibition
of state general funds
um
with an all-inclusive definition that
that's too much for me to accept
now we get back to what I'm keeping of
section 14 the syringe service programs
this is the one that allows the syringe
exchange but it also includes
specifically that the funds
being used by the opioid litigation
settlement can be used to support these
programs I think that makes a lot of
sense
it also includes drug checking and I
think drug checking is one of the most
important things that we can do in this
state right now we do not have a program
that provides both more confidence to
users that they're only using what they
intend to use when they buy drugs on the
street so they're looking at greater
harm and we don't know from a public
health or legal standpoint what else is
in these drugs we don't know if trank is
here in New Hampshire I think it's I
keep confusing that with a sweetener
Xylitol or whichever it is so I'll go
with the street name of tranq we assume
that it's here because it'd be crazy to
assume that it's not but we don't know
the prevalence we don't know how much is
is contaminated with that
so I I think that that is absolutely
critical I think that's very important
um I had kept 15 and 16 which were
around the physician's assistance and
the Physicians and surgeons but with our
discussion earlier I almost think that
it would make sense to leave that in the
hands um of their their authority to
write the prescriptions for this because
if there's already a program that's done
in order to be able to write
prescriptions for Controlled Substances
I don't think we need to duplicate that
and then provide training that won't be
used by people who don't pursue that
license
um so I would look to potentially have a
couple of those changes but I want to
talk about why I think it's so important
to be able to assess those risks by
having the drug checking stations if you
don't know what risk you're taking you
can't truly assess that risk I recognize
that when you're chasing a high your
your risk and reward ratio may be a
little bit different than somebody who
hasn't encountered that same challenge I
mentioned jumping off a cliff without a
parachute I used to jump out of planes
for fun and one of the big things we did
every spring is we sat down with safety
day we talk about how people died in the
previous year and try and figure out so
that we and our friends wouldn't be
those people that died
I am a relative newcomer to the sport
but as equipment improved and as it
wasn't equipment malfunctions that were
killing people we still had the same
number of people dying
when something becomes safer people take
bigger risks it's called risk
homeostasis and that is one of the big
problems around mitigating some of the
natural consequences of of choices if
you jump out of a out of a plane you're
not going to be able to break the laws
of gravity you need to make sure that
you're prepared and one of the biggest
reasons to tell people not to use drugs
is because quite frankly they'll destroy
your life and your health and they may
kill you and the people around you it's
not a good decision to make but taking
away basically making it so that all
everything wraps around you and supports
you because you've fallen into this big
challenge takes away a lot of the reason
why people don't use drugs in the first
place and I think that that actually may
be a cause of harm and not a harm
reduction scenario when we make when we
make it too easy and too nice
facing abuse is never easy but we also
need to make sure that
when you're when somebody is at a party
faced with that consequence they're
saying
you know I've heard heroin feels really
good but I also know that there's that
the most likely way to get out of a
heroin addiction is death
and I don't want to take that it's not
worth that risk because it's that first
decision about whether to use or not to
use that that really locks people into a
path you know I've known too many people
with addiction I I'm just very very
cautious about stepping in too quickly
into this massive harm reduction I think
that this amendment
we could do a couple changes to it about
which sections but I think that this
amendment gives us the capabilities to
meet this challenge without going too
far
so that's why I brought this Broad and
sweeping Amendment and I thank you for
your um
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
offering this amendment
um before this amendment came my vote on
the main bill was a hard no there's just
I'm not going to bore you with all the
reasons why I'm just a hard no
um but this is such a huge Amendment
with so many different changes that out
of respect to the Senate and out of
respect to representative Leon I feel
like
I couldn't vote on this right now I feel
like I would need to go home in a quiet
space and sit down and really read
everything that's been removed in order
for me to I mean maybe maybe enough of
the things I don't like from the main
Bill have been removed that I could
support it and but I couldn't do that
right now I mean this is I mean we just
spent like an hour talking about some
amendment that has like two lines change
and now we're talking about potentially
something that has like half the bill
removed so I appreciate the work which
you've obviously put a lot into into
doing this and I think that personally
for me it would be it would just it
wouldn't make sense to make a vote on
that today I don't know if we can do
something to just like put this off and
come back next week and then but if if
if this got passed today I still would
vote no on the bill because I don't
fully know what just got passed with the
amendment I it's just too much for me to
sit here and talk about I have to read
it by myself so thank you
oh the discussion representative Nagel
thank you that's really very Broad and
thoughtful I appreciate that
um two one comment one thought
um both accountants
um I think everything we talked about
this before this whole issue of defining
things and and I threw out what I
thought was helping what other people
thought was helpful but I I
I think it it does warrant a very large
discussion on what those issues mean and
I appreciate that but I think we do need
to develop a format to do that if we if
we're going to talk about that the other
thing that I wanted to talk about harm
reduction is I I've been involved with
the national project for about five
years at looking at Athletics and
developed a concept called justifiable
Risk by you know the decisions that make
people make when they decide to engage
in athletics which is not tremendously
different from what we're talking about
here
um one of the things that became clear
in interviewing people from all over the
country is the concept of putting an
adult in the room to make decisions so I
kind of look at harm reduction as a
multi-tiered thing not just the person
making that choice but then people at
multiple other levels having some
oversight or whatever setting Community
standards whatever terms you want to use
to help people make wiser choices I
don't think it comes just down to that
individual's Choice
um and I know that's simplistic but
that's what we came up with
um
so I don't want to narrow that
definition of harm reduction too much to
just that individual's choice I want to
make it broader than that but I do think
it's important that we go forward with
an important discussion about these and
we could you know this is a national
issue we could make a policy that would
go to other states whether they want to
use it or not so that's important
representative Merchant and
representative Netter upper thank you
sure
a question to representative Leon first
of all thank you for pointing out your
concerns
most of the concerns that I heard
revolve around the word harm reduction
almost every single section that you're
looking to remove from this
includes the word harm reduction
if we come up with a definition of harm
reduction
that we all can support would that
remove a lot of the objections to the
other sections you're looking to
eliminate
thank you very much for that question I
think
um I know I appreciate the work that
representative Nagel put into his
definitions I actually found that
definition of harm reduction to be
overly broad because that would include
housing for people who had addiction
editions issues it would include so many
different potential things that I think
that it's reaching too far I guess the
question around that would be
potentially a straw poll about whether
people think that that definition was
too loose or too broad and that would
give us an idea of if we would reach
some sort of agreement on a definition
of that today
um I must agree with representative Seth
King this is far too much to digest to
vote on today as last week I said can we
read them ahead of time so we can think
about them I need to read it
representative Shapiro and then
representative McKay
um I would also agree with
representative King that um maybe we
need to
recess or come back to this next week
since we're going to be meeting anyway I
I do want to express my concerns about
one of the things that representative
Leon said which is that um
or what I think she said which was on
the one hand harm reduction is a
positive because it keeps people from
harming themselves more than they
otherwise would on the other hand we
need to keep the potential harms
available to people because this is the
thing that actually will motivate them
to stop using drugs so to to me those
two things contradict each other
dramatically and
um
and I believe in harm reduction so I'm
concerned about I'm
uh that's this is different than
um taking more time to to
um kind of digest the amendment
um but I um I just want to express my
concern about
um
about making sure the potential harms
and risks remain because those are going
to be the things that get people off
drugs and um
nothing is black and white but I I guess
I don't agree with that
well representative McKay and then
representative Koval then representative
land thank you Mr chairman uh
what concerns me is
the the
changing the governor's Commission on
alcohol and drug abuse prevention
treatment and Recovery I was once a
member of this committee it seems to me
it's been well organized and well run
for many years and I have some grave
concern as to how we get to this
uh based on what we've been discussing
it seems to me that this is a
changing something that is well
established and I don't hear anybody
that has
talked to the governor's Commission
as to its and as to the need for change
so I'm very concerned about that part of
it
representative Koval
thank you Mr chairman so I mean I I do
want to
sort of remind people I there there was
there was one statement made in um
in in the testimony on this bill that I
that really stands out for me is that
you know someone saying that people come
to me and they say
um
the syringe service program saved my
life so I think that that is something
I'm trying to keep in mind as as I
deliberate on this one at the same time
I do have these serious concerns and I
think that the the definition of harm
reduction
as as the vice chair has pointed out
it's it's a
it's it's still a very broad definition
and I'm not even sure we can agree on
whether
harm reduction and treatment are two
distinct things or whether harm
reduction or whether treatment is a
subset of harm reduction as we heard
today whether they're two separate
things as we heard in the hearing or
whether
harm reduction is a subset of treatment
as if you read the bill he talks about
treatment including harm reduction so I
I just I think that there's there's a
lot of real fuzziness I think a lot of
the people who are talking about this
sort of have an idea of what they know
what what they're what they're talking
about but I think that when it comes
down to it it seems like there is a
tremendous lack of clarity around what
these things mean and if there is a
successful program in place and if
people are saying this saved my life
that's great we should you know we
should continue to do what we can to
save lives
my concern is that as we as we change
that as we expand that let's make sure
that we're doing this properly so that
we're not opening the door
to something that nobody's really clear
at this point what it is so that that's
my concern about the bill I support the
amendment
um because I think it it removes a lot
of that lack of clarity or a lot of
those areas that are very unclear
representative Leon and then
representative Nagel uh thank you Mr
chairman
um the first that I want to say is I was
trying to do something so that I could
support the good that's in this bill I
received the language of this amendment
at 9 25 a.m
um and it just picked it up from
upstairs so sorry that it was so late
um to representative Shapiro's Point um
I'm trying to make sure that we do have
the syringe exchange and the drug
checking in place and to have some
taxpayer-funded harm reduction efforts I
think that that larger conversation
um part of that question is how much of
that comes from taxpayers where we're
authorizing any sort of harm reduction
and how much can come and potentially if
you're private funding or something else
show that other modalities of harm
reduction do actually reduce that harm
and lead to less drug use as opposed to
just changing the course for people who
are using drugs or potentially increased
drug use so I think that we need to be
careful of those consequences that's why
instead of just opposing the bill I'm
trying to figure out how to have the
syringe service programs and the drug
checking in here and then representative
McKay my Amendment actually reduces the
changes that are being made to the
commission it does keep that change with
having the police Chiefs in there but
otherwise I remove most of those changes
to the commission
representative Nagel I guess
okay were you referring to the entire
bill or just the um the amendment or the
that uh that we're dealing with now may
I answered go ahead
I'm very concerned about the Amendment
uh which modifies the membership and
Reporting requirements of the governor's
Commission on alcohol and drug abuse
that's part of it it seems to me that
that's the bill though not the amendment
that's it
I'm sure I understand it it seemed like
you were happy with the way things are
and you didn't want to see any changes
am I wrong about that
uh okay I'm not very happy with any part
of this but I am concerned about uh
changing something as significant
as this without going into
some study beforehand it just seems to
be an afterthought
and
I would like to if
I don't see any need to modify
the governor's commission as it is in
the first place but if we were to do
that I think that this bill should be
retained and yeah I just wanted to if I
could um the reason why the bill was was
brought up was to me twofold
um number one I was involved in the
Department of Health and Human Services
interagency Task Force on creating a
unified statement on pain management
that involved 13 different federal
agencies it was really entertaining at
best
um mostly to just keep the acronyms
straight but
what I've also been impressed with in
this state is that we're seeing
increasing numbers of agencies that need
to work together and I think that one of
the reasons that this bill came is
number one is to allow them to
coordinate their services better and
Jennifer tell me if I'm wrong but
um you know to coordinate their services
better use up-to-date and unified
nomenclature
um
and if you look at the governors um that
you that you were on the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
there is a very well defined section
here on harm reduction so as we went
forward with the opio debatement
commission that was one of the things
that was asked if we could include that
in the opioid abatement commission so
including harm reduction in the terms
was important and that's why it was
added I totally understand the concept
of defining what that means and that's a
challenge and maybe we should spend more
time on that but that's why those
changes were made it wasn't to recreate
any Wheels it was it was done to
actually improve the interaction of
different agencies together I think that
responds to my concern under that that
this is leading to significant changes
that I
have and it's not
believing that the that this commission
is not fulfilling its responsibilities
okay
yeah representative uh Floyd Lloyd I'm
sorry hi as a substitute and knowing
that I may not be here when this is
again discussed I would just like to
throw out there I did appreciate the
note about specific to the licensure
changing
um possibly impacting like veterinarians
and and those types of services and I
just urge the committee to really be
very careful about DEA licenses
um and and the process to get those
specific to Animal Welfare agencies I
know that things drugs like ketamine
xylazine those types of things are used
in procedures
um
uh to sedate animals so I just uh keep
that in mind please thank you
representative Shapiro
obviously this has become very
complicated and um
and
it's it's
so one question I have is whether to put
this up till next week and refine some
of these amendments or to retain the
bill
so that it can be worked on and more
over more time and with more depth but
I'm unsure about what the
urgency is from the Department of
um Health and Human Services if we were
to retain the bill and what the
consequences would be I'm I I know
there's some things about funding for
some of these services so I wonder if we
could hear from them about what the
consequences would be of retaining the
bills so we can have all the discussion
that people are saying we need I mean
keep in mind we already have quite a few
retained bills but uh yeah could
somebody from the Department come
forward and and address this
Danielle Higgins I'm legislative liaison
for Behavioral Health for DHHS and so
this bill did come from representative
Waters who sits on the governor's
commission the governor's commission was
is you know after the study committee on
harm reduction the recommendations came
out of that legislative study committee
on harm reduction and were discussed
with the governor's commission so it's
not a department bill but it would be
really helpful in opening up the funding
to help make sure that we have every
tool in our toolbox to curb overdose and
be able to get more Upstream in our
prevention and intervention services
okay thank you representative
so um is the funding that you're talking
about just Federal funding not State
funding
because I think that's a concern always
the scope of the legislation opens up
harm reduction services to availability
of state and federal funding which would
include abatement and Governor's
commission funds neither neither of
which touch General funds just
specifically would open up these other
funding sources that are available to
New Hampshire so what do you view as the
biggest consequence if we do retain this
bill
we just have less Avail available
funding for the potential of these harm
reduction services
okay for like another year until we
passed it right so the opioid abatement
funding in particular has allowed the
state of New Hampshire to fill gaps in
current funding sources and the purpose
of making sure that we can also fund
harm reduction Services is to reduce
overdose fatalities
thank you very much representative land
did you have your hand up
um thank you Mr chairman
um so it sounds like there are no
current funding requests in so if we
were to take this up and and it came to
the floor in January versus May
um would there be there wouldn't be a
direct impact it would just be about
future requests is that correct there
are current requests in for harm
reduction Services actually today at GNC
there are sick the first 16
um of the opioid abatement Grant
Agreements are at GNC today so that the
the opioid abatement funds are beginning
to move at this point and the governor's
commission already is has been doing
this work for a number of years so that
the funding is in motion and the
expansion of availability of funds for
syringe Services programs is the scope
of the legislation before you
that availability of that funding to go
to that specific carbon auction program
representative Nagel um I just expand on
that I mean one of our big tasks right
now is to solicit War grants and
um that would I would assume would
affect what types of Grants we could
solicit at this point so that's a now
thing am I correct yes I mean we're
meeting on
it's Monday to talk about that so that's
important representative Merchant
for clarification
this RSA governs the abatement program
or the abatement program has its own RSA
under its own guidelines I'm getting
confused here between what role the
abatement program has in its funding
mechanism and what it's allowed to do
versus this bill
interfering with that so I'm not sure
exactly but one's going to augment it
one's going to displace it can you help
clarify the role of this bill versus the
role coming from the abatement funding
program
I apologize I don't have the bill in
front of me to point you to the specific
sections but there are sections of the
legislation around the governor's
commission sections of the legislation
around opioid abatement commission and
then sections of the legislation around
harm reduction syringe Services programs
that allow for the available funding to
be used for those purposes in any of all
state and general funds and so I'm sorry
um not General funds federal and state
funding and so that the that last
section around syringe Services Program
is the piece that opens up the
availability of those other funding
sources I was mentioning which are other
sections of the bill
uh representative Nagel um Senate Bill
32 that we passed
um that was the big addition was harm
reduction
um and so
um
that was adding harm reduction to one of
the 17
um potential items for soliciting funds
from the opioid abatement commission
that was not in there before
representative Merchant again I'm really
lost
so on Senate Bill 32 which we passed
that deals with the use of the abatement
funds which includes harm reduction
that bill added there's 17 or there were
16 entities by which you could solicit
fund or right solicit or put a grant and
whatever
harm reduction was added as part of that
bill
so so that's now a reason why you can
ask for funds well it's not yet it has
to pass the governor but we'll go back
to again the same thing if we retain
this bill
it's nothing prohibits somebody from
going to the abatement program and
asking for Grants correct for harm
reduction I don't know well there is
that last section of this bill around
syringe services that say that state
funding cannot be utilized and so the
abatement funds are State funding and so
it is making sure that while today
programs can apply to the abatement fund
under that our harm reduction programs
we have in statute that syringe Services
can't receive federal and state funds
and that's the change being made in this
bill before you
representative Palmer
so my question is listening to
representative Leon's Amendment
would per Amendment if that passed would
would that work and enable These funds
to be accessed maybe maybe you have to
look into that a little bit more but
that's sort of like a seems to me a key
question
yes unfortunately I just would need to
review what those parts of the bill that
are the sections that are being removed
a little bit more in depth before I felt
like I could answer that
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman um and thank you as you look
into this to me
um it looks like the big key in this is
section 14 the controlled Drug Act
syringe service programs that allows
um the federal funds to be used for drug
checking drug cracking equipment drug
supplies eligible activities and that it
provides that permission in order to use
those funds that that to me is the most
important part of the bill and that's
what I was looking to preserve I know
that you speak to a Prohibition on
syringe services for State funds however
section 13 that strikes it just just
prohibits state general funds it doesn't
prohibit any of these other special
funds and so I I would be would be very
interested to know if just that section
14 if we pass just that if that would
get us through to be able to introduce a
bill in the coming year to then address
the rest of these issues and not hold up
a pressing need to offer greater
services and access that funding in
order to deal with these more esoteric
parts
so
I wish I had a very direct clear answer
for you today but it is something I feel
like I need to review further
uh yes representative Merchant thank you
I'd like to call on representative
walner who's from the finance problem
understands this better than I
my understanding the way the money is
Flowing from the opiate abatement
programs go into a designated fund not
into the general fund so therefore the
questions are very representative
Wallner is that if the funds from the
abatement program are going to a
designated fund and therefore not that
the general funds is in fact on page
four
lines 18.
about the use of General funds
how does that impact because if they're
not going to the general funds but it's
in a designated fund is that in fact
outside of the general funds
could you use the microphone
representative okay
I've been trying to read it on my phone
so it's a little it's a little hard to
to really
see it I mean when I see in the original
bill
that you have what it looks like to me
is what
um
that they were
proposing by striking out the use of
state general funds they they struck
that out that prohibition and would
allow the allow any it looks like any
state funds to be used for this purpose
and I would ask the attorney if that is
her agreement with that
so my expertise is in Behavioral Health
if I'm not an attorney so just want to
clarify
I that would have that again would just
have to be a question for someone with
more familiar with the general funds
thank you representative cofult
yes so I believe that the question was
asked of the primary sponsor
um why that that section of Statute
would would be stricken in this uh in
this bill
and the answer we heard at that time was
well we just thought it was a good a
good thing to do in case we want to use
General funds in the future and that was
put in in order to pass the original
bill but I think everybody recognizes
the value of syringe services at this
point so
um you know forgive me if I'm not
remembering that with you know Precision
but uh that that was the general gist of
his statement and
um you know it seems to me that that
would align with the the statement that
um
you know allowing for for use of the
opioid abasement fund abatement fund
would not
um
would not be prohibited if if we were to
restore that language or or to remove
the that section that would strike out
that language from statute
okay many other discussion
I'm seeing none we have a motion on the
floor but I'm hearing
mixed mixed signals here um
representative Leon is Joe motion um
thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm thinking
that with all these moving pieces and
would knowing that the next big one is
large I was wondering if we could just
recess for another earlier lunch that
way we have time if anything was going
to go to OLS and that way we can sort of
think about if if we can get some
answers when we come back from lunch
about whether that's section 14 on the
syringe program would be enough to get
us through to next year just to get some
information on that so that we we can
have a little bit more information
before we move that would be my
suggestion but I'm well an hour's lunch
be sufficient I would do you do you
think we need more time than that
it would probably be sufficient but I'm
not sure if anybody else has other lunch
plans if you should come back at one any
thoughts on this does that seem to be a
potential solution representative I I
don't think an hour is going to get us
where we need to feel comfortable about
voting on this amendment or not
um
I would prefer to
table it to next week
and then we can decide whether we're
gonna
um
retain it and prefer to move on to the
next bill and be done earlier but anyway
that's
representative King you had a similar
concern what do you think about this
um
I don't know upon upon more studies well
all those everybody was talking I I
don't think I'll be able to support the
main Bill even if this amendment were to
pass uh so on the one hand I think to
myself well I should vote for the
amendment because it makes a bad Bill
less bad on the other hand I don't want
to necessarily help the bill get passed
so I'm in a quandary it's a political
quandary I know but um I don't know take
that as you will I always will vote for
longer lunches though because I am the
slowest eater here so
thank you
okay well yes representative Merchant
I would support
um to table this until next week but
also I would like to be sure that during
the time
there were tabling this that we don't
just wait until next week to continue
the conversation that we actually have a
group of us sit down and talk about it
but more importantly before we even move
forward I'd like to get clarification
about the language on page four about
the general funds versus opiate funds
because if that is not the case where
opiate of even funds can in fact be
utilized in that capacity than we could
possibly even retain this and work on it
for a longer period of time so I guess
my question to the chair how do we find
out who do we speak to to find out in
fact
that opiate of even funds are not
considered General funds that are
outside of it
and then at that point in time would
help me make the decision whether to
retain this and then move forward
sometime next fall
um
good question
uh representative Nagle let me think
about that
um I there's multiple vehicles to answer
that question but we have a meeting of
the opioid abatement Commission on
Monday
um I can certainly reach out before that
um to the person who really knows a lot
about that stuff before that
um
um as far I just wanted to bring one
other point up I'm a new legislator I do
not feel comfortable in making new
dramatic changes in language to an
amendment on the Fly I just don't think
it's good practice so I would rather
table two okay representative Murphy no
I would I would Echo the same sentiment
I am
I wouldn't say totally confused but I am
somewhat confused
um with all the different changes that
we've talked about so if we had the
opportunity of seeing
the Amendments that Dr I mean that
representative Leon came up with but
also the opportunity to perhaps work
with Dr Nagel about tweaking some of his
language as well in his three amendments
having that in front of me over the next
week would be so much easier for me to
digest and understand and I think we
would save a lot of time doing that
okay all right the motion is on the
floor representative land which are
plots I can withdraw my motion okay
uh who and who seconded that
representative Cushman and you would
draw also yes okay so the sentiment is
to continue this until next week is that
correct okay we'll continue
um Senate Bill 239 until next week
do we need to like create a subcommittee
or do we just leave that as
random discussion I don't think random
discussion is a good idea
representative representative Leon did
you want to speak to that um uh thank
you Mr chairman
um the
if it's a ad hoc group of um some number
of people that are less than a quorum
there can be some discussion in order to
address those problems and bring them
back to the great the larger group we
can't have discussions as a group
outside of these public hearings because
that's our transparency but we can have
people go and reach those targeted
things we can send an amendment to the
people in the group so that they can see
it but we just can't have discussions
outside this is an early bill by the way
so one way or another we need we need to
make a decision next week whether it's
retain or of other action yeah
representative Merchant again for
clarification development representative
Leon
if this is an ad hoc group and it's not
a quorum not enough members of the
community to create a quorum
how we permitted to meet via Zoom
virtually versus being in person it
would make it easy I think for some of
us
I would say if it's an and Ms Dyer might
be able to advise us better on this but
if it's an informal group
I would I would think a zoom would be
would be feasible am I right about that
I am right about that so
okay any other thoughts on uh Senate
Bill 239
all right we will continue that until
next week along with 240.
and moving on to everybody's favorite
although at this point that we know this
is going to be a long discussion do we
want a break for lunch and um come back
and again the what you're talking about
is it going to be able to resolve in an
hour or should we just go to one of you
know balance it out
um I I think that there's a lot to be
discussed here
um if we're unless we're planning on
keeping our discussions to just a short
time and then adjourning at say one I
think it's better that we get some
sustenance for the discussion ahead okay
representative Shapiro I would just like
to Second
um that opinion um I would personally
since
um judging from the discussion about the
last bill the discussion about the next
bill could go on for some time so I
would like to um I would like to break
for lunch but not make it an extended
um lunch in Siesta so we can get back as
soon as possible 12 45 how does that
work
it will break for just a little over an
hour we come back at 12 45.
thank you
foreign
an afternoon and we're back
a few minutes late but we're back for
the afternoon session
um
we have covered as much as we're going
to today the four of the five bills that
were noticed in the calendar
the one remaining bill for us to
consider this afternoon is Senate bill
263.
and um at this point uh representative
Leon did you have a motion uh yes thank
you Mr chairman I move that we retain
house bill 263.
representative Cushman seconds
you want to speak to your motion uh yes
thank you Mr chairman there's a lot of
confusion around Medicaid and Medicaid
expansion we've received hundreds of
different emails and a lot of them are
actually talking about people with
disabilities children other groups that
are covered by traditional Medicaid so I
I think that I think that that's one
area of confusion where we need to make
sure that we understand what it is that
we're dealing with here
um there's also a lot of confusion about
how this is in the statutes so right now
Medicaid's in the state of flux because
we're unwinding the public health
emergency we have this language even
with all of its flaws in the budget it
has a sunset in the budget and I support
that I support our position that's in
the budget and I think that that's the
right place for something of this
magnitude if we're going to keep moving
this forward I truly think the best
place for this bill is in our committee
working through the summer and the fall
and looking at the fact that our
statutes about half of the language
switch of two 126 double A is actually
expired because it says on or before
this date we must do X it shows that
there are reasons why we needed to put
in requests for waivers and other things
that were conditional and based on a
time frame this is something that
encourages having a renewal date and
having a sunset because
a lot of people here probably don't want
to touch the hot potato and Medicaid
expansion if we weren't up against the
sunset I can guarantee you this wouldn't
be in front of us but our job here is to
do the challenging difficult work of
looking at our programs and making sure
that they're operating as we expect
um so as we look at this our current law
lives in a couple places there's five
sections in 126 double A and then
there's some that's in chapter law of
course it's hard to tell which parts of
chapter law are still in effect because
as I was digging into all of this
um in 2018
the chapter law that stated that there
was an expiration
based on federal funding was revising
chapter law from two previous times the
idea of having something of this
magnitude sprinkled across not just the
rsas but also chapter law
makes a confusing issue even more
confusing and passing this bill as we
have it does nothing to solve that
Clarity issue
um then there was also the ones where we
had a law that had a waiver request
recent history has shown that when the
legislature wants the department or any
Department to submit a waiver we need to
put that in writing and we need to put
that into statutes that's one of those
things that also gives that emphasis for
them to pursue that waiver and perhaps
may give a little bit more heft when
it's received down in DC because it's
not just a department it's an apartment
at the behest of the legislature and
Governor making that request for a
waiver if you look across the country at
the whole Medicaid Program it's a system
built upon waivers so just because we're
asking for a waiver for this that or the
other doesn't mean that it doesn't mean
that we're not following the law it's
what it's based upon and so I I really
believe that this committee is the best
place to work on this you know
we're the ones who understand what
people are going through we have medical
professionals who have seen both sides
of of the benefits of having patients
with Medicaid and some of the challenges
of serving people with Medicaid we have
people who have constituents who are
talking about Services now
I actually found out that we've had a
sterilization Bill earlier about that
right I found out in New Hampshire
Medicaid will not pay for a hysterectomy
unless you're over 37 or have children
now that's the sort of thing we can fix
when these things come up but it's very
very hard to do without having a sunset
and I I guess one other part that I do
want to make clear because it is so
challenging is the difference between
Medicaid and Medicaid expansion
if you have disabilities you are on
Medicaid that is one of the waivers if
you're a kid you're on the children's
health insurance plan which is rolled
into our traditional Medicaid lower
income families are in traditional
Medicaid and retirees that need a
supplement for long-term care or on
traditional Medicaid none of those are
up for this discussion that is something
that is in federal law we've agreed with
and we're we're going down that path
forever hand in hand till even past till
the death to us part because this
survives all of us but Medicaid
expansion is that creation that came
about from the Affordable Care Act it
was a way in order to figure out how to
bridge that Gap and provide government
paid health care because if you were
going to force people to get coverage
you had to provide a solution it took us
a long time to get to the point where we
are here in New Hampshire
we'd walk through a couple different
Pathways but as we walk down those
Pathways you know we figured out what we
needed to do in order to get to the next
step but I don't think this program is
as strong as it could be if we really
worked together in order to figure this
out and you know lastly I also want to
talk about there's a lot of efforts to
increase the minimum wage there's a lot
of efforts to make sure that people are
being paid a living wage
but when you look at the cap on Medicaid
expansion at 138 percent of the federal
poverty level when you take away the
five percent hold back that means that
for a family of two they can't make more
than twenty seven thousand two hundred
thirteen dollars and sixty cents a year
so that means that if both of them are
working for 100 hours a month which
would be the work requirement if it's
reinstated they couldn't make more than
11.34 cents an hour
so in order to qualify for these
benefits you're being locked into lower
income work and that's a really really
difficult position to be in so then if
you had both of the family members and
that two-member adult-only household
working full-time well unless they were
servers who didn't get good tips they
couldn't because if you're making 7.25
an hour the federal minimum wage with
two people in the household you don't
qualify for that so we need to look and
see what it is that we're doing one of
the
um so I have a number of different
solutions to get us closer to our rights
right right path
um
I I mean when you look at this it's a
program that really keeps people stuck
in order to meet a need which is Health
Care
and we can't just pass this into the
future with no Sunset and let this keep
going without taking on the important
task of trying to make this better
trying to make it stronger and also
trying to make sure that we ask for what
the people of New Hampshire need you
know if you if you look at this we had
we basically had rules passed down from
DC as to how our hospitals could operate
during covet because of the threat of
the loss of Medicaid money
if we had had a position of submitting
waivers for anything that's contrary to
New Hampshire law we may have kept some
more Health co-workers by having more
flexibility
and I think that this is our opportunity
to look at this so what I would suggest
doing
um is we have a couple different
amendments on these you know we're not
really going to take them up but I want
to discuss the different issues that we
have with the program and sort of
concretely tell you how we could fix it
so it isn't just the esoteric idea where
we sort of talked around each other last
week because just like the last bill
um you know there's good in this but
there's a lot that can be improved and I
think that we probably should take some
time to do that so um I'll probably ask
to be recognized later on but I think
I've spoken for
long enough stretch of time thank you
representative Shapiro
I'm going to vote against the motion to
retain the bill
um
not only did this pass the Senate 24-0
the business the business community
supports this bill the health care
providers support this bill this bill is
provided Health Care to
approximately sixty thousand Granite
Staters
the information that Senator Bradley
gave when he introduced the bill talked
about the amount of churn among people
who have been on Medicaid expansion in
other words people did not just remain
on Medicaid expansion and become
dependent that it actually supported
people's resilience and um
allowed people to be healthy enough to
go to work I could talk for a long time
and I'm not going to talk anymore but I
would I would hope that we could have a
vote fairly quickly about this so that
we can get on with
um the discussion about what if anything
we're going to change
uh representative Palmer
so representative Shapiro
started with the first several of my
reasons why I won't I will vote against
retaining the biggest ones are
um in addition to the Senate voting 24
to nothing every single
comment I've had from my constituents
has been in favor of passing this bill
our hospital system is at a crisis point
this is a key piece for now regardless
of whether you don't think our current
medical system is is a mess I completely
agree but if you take a take it try to
take it apart piece by piece it's just
going to collapse right now and there'll
be at least 60 000 people without health
care if we don't pass this and they'll
be you know other disruptions in the
medical system that will affect more
people if we don't keep this going so I
I think we need to move forward in a way
to make sure that this becomes law this
year
uh representative King Seth King thank
you Mr chair
um
I think to address
um both Representatives concerns
the fact that it was overwhelmingly
passed in the Senate much to my chagrin
Medicaid expansion is is popular it
seems pretty popular so
um I think what that actually says to me
is that you need not fear future
legislators or legislative bodies
um getting rid of Medicaid expansion if
it if it is as popular as we think it is
but um the permanency is I think
dangerous really for any any program I
wouldn't support I don't think I would
support permanency for any sort of
program let the legislators next session
deal with these things
so that's my stance it's it's a popular
program even though I don't personally
like it and I don't see what the fear is
of just letting it continue on normally
thank you
representative Coachman thank you Mr
chairman
um I understand that it did pass the
Senate 24 to zero but we are at our own
body and we are elected by our
constituents to vote how we believe we
should we should vote and
um there are after combing through this
program there are so many things in it
that are not
I don't see them as being the New
Hampshire way of doing things it seems
that it's just we took a cookie cutter
Federal program and put it into our laws
we've heard the statements that there
are protections for taxpayers in this
but
um and you know perhaps it's in chapter
law but as it's written right now that
in in the RSA 126 double a
um in section
uh Roman I'm sorry section three Roman
six
um that Severance Clause where you've
been told well we've heard that um if
the federal government stops paying
their 90 share and they reduce it that
the program ends well that's that's
actually not what it says
um there in the statute and it's been
changed and I actually have a a paper
which my caucus has so if we could pass
some of these out to
um
the other members of the committee that
would be wonderful shows the evolution
of that that text
um since about 2014 so there have been
it's been kind of chipped away at over
time and now really the only way that um
uh this program will be
um if we don't have the money in the
trust fund the granite Advantage Health
Plan trust fund to cover it
um it used to be that
um there was a trigger you know if it
went under 95 by this year the 95 4 by
this year
down to 90 percent of uh where it was
and I believe 2019 was the last year
that's been removed completely now it
the RSA only says that if there's
nothing if the commissioner finds that
there are not sufficient funds in The
Liquor Commission fund to cover a
shortfall
then the program will be terminated
and that Liquor Commission fund that's
literally the the liquor commission's
budget so unless the Liquor Commission
goes bankrupt which would indicate that
the state of New Hampshire is in very
Dire Straits and probably the entire
country's economy is in shambles
you know the the program there is no
safety valve for that program to be
um
you know responsibly
terminated so the language that was
supposed to be in there to protect it is
not here in the statute and if it's
somewhere in chapter law
um
I was not able to find it
so to me it looks like we don't have
that protection and that's a big problem
for me because the federal government
the um
the Congressional budget office has
stated that they it recommends that the
that Congress increased the Medicaid
rates decrease I'm sorry
increase the state portion of Medicaid
so they'll be looking for us to pay a
bigger share of this eventually and if
they change it
it looks to me that there is no Clause
here that allows us to back out of the
program without taking on that extra
financial responsibility that we didn't
agree to
so I would like to see that changed
there are issues
with this commission and
um you know the way that this is funded
I don't see it going into the budget in
hb2 there's some language that it will
be in the budget
going forward so that
um it can be looked at like everything
else I'm just going to bring up the
language specifically but this is this
is missing from this bill so I'd like to
see what's in hb2 go forward we retain
this maybe we add
um add that clause and fix some of these
other issues first
um but that language that I'm talking
about
States
um
sorry
I'm not going to come up now
well it basically it doesn't go through
the normal budget process so we want it
to do that
um
another issue that I found
this one
that's the shortfall
um the work requirement so we've seen
that there's been some movement on that
Georgia has now managed to get a work
requirement for Medicaid in their state
the details of which I have not had the
chance to thoroughly dive into but I
think that we sh there is an opportunity
here and that we should be
um
requiring the commissioner to submit a
request for approval of our community
engagement requirements that are in
statute
these are things that make the program
tailored to the values of New Hampshire
you know we want those protections for
taxpayers we want to keep a
responsibility aspect in this program
and if we can do that the New Hampshire
way it should be done that way we don't
do things like every other state we do
it our way
and that's why we have the New Hampshire
advantage
there are other other issues that um I
can touch on as things as things move
forward but the bottom line is there are
a lot of holes there's a lot of room for
reform and I don't think that we should
be making the perm the program as it
currently is permanent I think the
two-year Sunset
um is perfectly reasonable and is enough
time for
um
people to come together with now we have
a lot of great ideas and a good jump off
point to make this program tailored to
our values here in the state thank you
another discussion
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair
I will be voting also to
not support retention of the bill
I think I could speak to a couple of
concerns that I heard one is about the
budgetary process my understanding is
probably going to go to finance so the
airport it's an appropriate way to be
vetted through the finance which is a
budgetary process
I do support representative King's
comment it's a popular program
but the next question why is it popular
because it actually helps a lot of
people and I heard from the business
Community it helps them as well bringing
down premiums and if you're looking at
trying to find ways to encourage
employers to offer health insurance one
of the ways to do that is to bring down
the premium costs because they can
afford to give it to their employees
without having high deductibles
I do want to bring out the fact that in
Sullivan County which I do have here in
front of me in Claremont and Croydon by
itself is over 1700 people that are
benefiting from this program
also within Sullivan County with 60
million dollars added to the Coopers of
providers and so forth I do understand
what representative Palmer's coming from
we have a very precarious situation
right now after covid with a lot of the
hospitals are struggling they are
literally on the edge of going under
if we don't find a way to help them
because ultimately they still get care
folks they just show up at the emergency
room which is uncompensated care
or rely upon the providers to provide
uncompensated care to them as well what
that creates is a pent up demand because
we don't take care of things early on
the old adage of penny
uh
announcement prevention is worth a pound
of cure and I think the same thing goes
through here that we have to be sure
that patients fundamentally have the
opportunity
to get the preventative care they need
to keep the costs from getting out of
control so for all those reasons I will
be voting against retention of the bill
also but if I can
the question about working on this over
the next two or three years and
retaining it that's the role of the
commission I mean the commission is
being created to fundamentally help
guide future legislation so if that
commission is doing what it's supposed
to do which I think it will
it's going to help guide our legislative
policy to make sound judgment
legislatively going forward so
representative Leon I hear what your
concerns are but we don't need to delay
it we actually are putting something in
place to help guide us in the future
other other discussion representative
Cushman
thank you Mr chairman and um thank you
representative Merchant because
um you
helped uh help me remember another point
that I wanted to make
um I understand that you know the Health
Care system was facing uncompensated
care
um and that one of the goals of Medicaid
expansion was to help deal with that to
help people get Primary Care before they
have to go to the hospital
um and you know reduce health care costs
that way and you know a lot of people
talk about the benefits of the program
you know we reduce costs here we've you
know
um you know this has improved but no one
really talks about the costs of the
program compared to those benefits and
you know the mcos get a capitated rate
um you know they get paid for every
person who's on the Medicaid rolls and
this program costs a lot of money and I
would submit that it costs a lot more
money to run the program than the
uncompensated care of all the hospitals
each year
and if that's the case then maybe this
is not the most financially responsible
way to do this and I think going back to
my point about doing things the New
Hampshire way that may be a voucher
system for Primary Care for Indigent
individuals or you know a Baseline
there's there's another way we could do
this not necessarily maybe Medicaid is
the best way
um but I think there's room for other
ideas to deal with this that could be
much more cost effective
um and that could be tailored
to be run the way that I think you know
um
historically New Hampshire residents
seem to like things to be very fiscally
responsible and tailored
to how we do it here
um so that's that's just you know bottom
line if this is costing more then
the cost um the uncompensated care that
we were looking to cover or if it's
costing more than you know a visit to a
primary care doctor for each of the
people in this enrollment plan and you
know their health care needs then it
doesn't really make sense and I think
that there is a better way to do this
and that more more discussion definitely
needs to take place and we shouldn't be
making it permanent today thank you
representative Cannon and then
representative Palmer
thank you Mr chair
I represent this small city of
Somersworth a small town of Rollinsford
and those people elected me to represent
them and the overwhelming amount of mail
I've received associated with this bill
is to pass it
you have to remember you have to think
remember we have communities
that are extremely low income that's a
big challenge for us in Somersworth we
have a lot of City
supported housing right now and many of
those people are on Medicaid we don't
have a whole lot of people making over
six figures and Somersworth or more
relinsford or even in the high double
digits you know it's it's
um
it's just a way of life in our
communities we've got to help our
community and and this bill will help
our community thank you
representative Palmer and then
representative Leon so uh the the other
thing about making significant changes
is program is the federal program and
they're paying 90 of the bill and
I run up against this all the time which
is that you want to fix something but
you can't fix it at the state or local
level it's got to be fixed in Washington
so a lot of the things that
representative Cushman and Leon are
talking about need to be fixed there we
can't we can't change a federal program
in New Hampshire we can decide whether
or not to take it but I think we have to
realize that if we're going to take it
we need to take it with its rules and
try to adapt as much as we can within
what the federal government will allow
but we we aren't going to be able to
make this a New Hampshire program
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman
um I think that one of the important
issues about having a sunset is keeping
that pressure on DC and on the federal
government to keep this as a program
that is responsive to the needs of the
states the more states that sign on in
perpetuity the less pressure there is in
order to keep it focused and the less
pressure there is in order to make sure
that it stays that is intended intended
role as opposed to going for a big big
scope Escape
big change in scope I apologize I should
have had more than coffee for lunch
um one of the other parts that I did
want to hit upon was the discussion
about the commission so initially when
the commission was created in 2018
it had generally the same makeup however
the only voting members of the committee
were the six legislative members and a
quorum was four of those six legislative
members now the voting members are three
members of the Senate three members of
the House of Representatives the
commissioner of DHHS the commissioner of
the Department of Insurance a
representative of each Managed Care
Organization awarded contracts under
this a representative of a hospital that
operates in New Hampshire a public
member with Healthcare expertise a
public member who currently receives
coverage through the program a public
member representing the interests of
small business in New Hampshire pronated
by the Chamber of Commerce a
representative of the medical care
advisory committee Department of Health
and Human Services appointed by the
commissioner a licensed physician
appointed by the New Hampshire Medical
Society a licensed mental health
Professor a professional appointed by
Nami a licensed substance use disorder
professional appointed by the New
Hampshire alcohol and drug abuse
Counselors Association an APRN appointed
by their Association the chairperson on
the governor's Commission on alcohol and
drug abuse prevention treatment or
recovery and designee and I believe that
there's also some effort in order to
include Josiah Bartlett Center and a
pharmacist in this as well but when you
look at this if everybody there is a
voting member
you have a lot of the groups that
benefit directly from this and few of
the groups that see the indirect harm
this is a program that the more that
it's expanded just about everybody who
is part of that commission they benefit
and I was an analyst on Wall Street of
course you act in your own interest in
the interest of those people you
represent now I I don't I don't uh
I don't think that it's a negative that
people are advocating effectively for
those people who they represent but I
believe as a legislature we need to make
sure that we aren't creating commissions
that are stacked for one outcome as
opposed to being able to look at both
the benefits the risks and more
specifically how we can craft craft
legislation to be more New Hampshire
specific through the waiver program that
does exist and is used robustly in the
state
I'll probably ask you to come back I
might wander if I get to my next topic
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
I would just like to say that I don't
think we're gonna any of us are going to
convince any of the rest of us about
whether this is a good idea or not and I
would implore our committee
to just take a vote on it
representative land
I think that without addressing the
significant underlying programs we miss
a very large opportunity in order to see
what can and should be improved for one
thing here we have in statutes a
reduction of poly Pharmacy resulting in
drug interaction harm as part of the
granted Advantage program we see
significant harm from polypharmacy a lot
of the the mass Shooters are on
polypharmacy we need to understand how
much that's happening within our
Medicaid system and so that we can at
least have a subset of data and
understand what risks we may be
encountering as an analyst I Look to
Sweden and they had a lot of great
population level data which let us get
an idea of Trends the way things worked
and what we could see but we need to
make sure that also with cardiac drugs
you can be a dog chasing your tail
because you add one after another and
another you increase the side effects
you increase the cost of the system
without necessarily increasing the
benefit to the patient that's the sort
of thing that we can do do something
about here in New Hampshire with
crafting our specific legislation sorry
that was RSA 126 double a colon 2
1g1e sorry I can pass this around so
that you can see it but this is just one
of those and also we were speaking to
the benefits of of having preventative
care
right now we don't require an annual
Wellness visit for somebody to
participate in this program if the whole
point is to get care early shouldn't an
annual Wellness visit be can one of the
conditions for continued coverage I
would argue that if we're trying to get
ahead of medical catastrophe it should
be so that is sorry
I was going one side
I think this is what's going here yes
here we go
so this is just one area where we could
make a difference and improve this and
improve the quality of care improve
outcomes
and improve things
Mr chairman
uh yes representative weren't we it
seems that a representative Leon is
introducing an amendment and I thought
we were in voting mode
uh well she didn't make any motion so
I'm thinking she yeah I believe she did
did you I'm sorry yes I had moved to
retain and part of my reason for
retaining is all of the massive changes
that we should I understand but I just
thought if we're in voting mode I would
like to vote and then if we're going to
be in Amendment mode we can be in
Amendment mode
I believe we're in discussion mode after
the motion I believe you just introduced
an amendment
you can pass that back that was for
discussion purposes to highlight how we
can make one specific change to the law
that we have in New Hampshire where
we're able to do some things but not all
so that was as an example I apologize we
can pass those back if you would like I
was just trying to be helpful
that's how I interpreted it as it was
just in support of her motion that she
had distributed that so but um we don't
we certainly don't want to money to
these Waters anymore so representative
Merchant
it's more of a comment than a discussion
but
regardless which way we go with this if
we do end up passing this bill I do
recommend highly
that we Advocate to the speaker that
grabs the delay on be one of the
representatives that's pointed to the
commission she has a lot of valuable
insight and knowledge I think it'd be
very valuable for that Commission
okay another discussion
on the discussion okay
um
you know I I suspect we know how this
motion might well go
um 10 10 probably
and says I suspect that's going to be
two of almost any motion that's made on
this bill today
we're going to continue two other bills
is this worth continuing until next week
no
representative Shapiro I think that
we've um you know if we haven't had the
last five years to think about this
we've certainly had
um the last few months to think about
this and to hear testimony and to talk
among our own caucus I'm sure the
Republicans have talked among their own
caucus I think that
[Music]
um
I think we probably have very different
opinions
um but I don't think that we're gonna
make things we're going to improve
things by taking more time
I think we're
um I guess I'm only speaking for myself
but I'm ready to vote on this and if
this doesn't pass
on various amendments that people have
and to discuss them and vote on them
okay anyone else want to comment on this
I could withdraw my motion
um if it looks like this is going to be
deadlocked I thought that I thought that
it would be pretty clear that we had
more work to do but I'm going to
withdraw my motion
okay so there is no motion on the floor
um
first I made a second should we draw two
yep
may be recognized for emotion
representative Cushman yes yes go ahead
um
going to introduce an amendment
I move that we pass
Amendment one six two two
um to SB 263 and I will pass that around
for everyone
foreign
was there a second to that motion
representative Leon seconds
representative Cushman do you want to
speak to your motion yes thank you so
going back to that discussion and that
um paper that I passed out to everybody
um
that you have about the evolution of
this section of rsa126 double A
um where it speaks to the federal match
rate and if that goes below 90 percent
um that that's not in statute anywhere
um so I would like to see that in the
rsas that govern this program and so the
amendment you have before you does just
that
um it puts in that if the fat you'll see
on line 13 if the federal match rate
applied to the program Falls below 90
percent
RSA 126 colon double a shall be repealed
180 days after the rate change occurs
and that the commissioner within 48
Hours of the rate change shall notify
the governor the Speaker of the House of
Representatives the president of the
Senate and the chairperson of the fiscal
Committee of the general court Secretary
of State and the director of legislative
Services of the program's pending
termination and within 10 business days
of the rate change notify program
participants of the program's pending
termination
so this just goes back to if if we are
touting this program as having these
taxpayer protections we better make sure
that they actually are in place and that
they are in the RSA and easily able to
be found and are very clear in common
language
and um
the beginning of the bill on line five
um it's just talking about when when
that part would take effect
representative South King thank you Mr
chair question for you representative
and that is
um is it your understanding that if this
provision were not in the bill and there
were some sort of you know deadlock in
spending from Congress or whatever and
the federal government didn't pay their
90 share that the
that the the state as it currently
stands would pick up the hundred percent
of the bill
yes that's my unders my understanding is
that we would have to because as of
right now the the 10 and 90 percent is
not anywhere in statute at all okay and
then my other question would be for
anybody else that could show me
otherwise if if representative Cushman
is incorrect I'd I'd like to see um I'd
like to see proof of that thank you
representative Murphy did you hand up oh
I'm sorry
another discussion on this amendment
representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman um I I'm
looking to find the specific things but
was your request your request to OLS was
to place this within the statutes into
the rsas is that correct uh they
actually they left this in chapter law
so this would need to go into chapter
law um I fully support moving
um the language from chapter law in 2018
into 126 double A because I think that
without that we're legislators we've
been trying to track this down for a
while with the help of OLS and it's
still been challenging thank you and
that's
uh thank you for pointing that out
because I specifically asked for them to
create a new section seven after section
six in that RSA so I expected that it
was going to be in the right place but I
I didn't catch that so thank you for
catching that
Mr chair
uh well I'm sorry Mr representative
Merchant just a point of water I'm
trying to go through the RSA that's
being referenced here
are we trying to change RSA 342 colon 25
may I respond sure go ahead um
representative Merchant so that's
chapter law and that's
um
that is
that is not what I was trying to do I
was trying to put it in RSA 126 colon a
a
uh I'm sorry
126-aa colon 3
and it would be a new section Roman 7.
is this amendment ready for us to
consider uh well well now that we've
pointed out that it's it's still not
putting it in the RSA no it is not I
would need all this it's true according
to what I'm saying it says grading and
marketing and sale of eggs
which is three four two right they're
referencing the chapter log on
representative Leon
okay
so
um
unfortunately it looks like that this
amendment is not ready for us to
introduce and this just furthers the
point why I think that we need to retain
this so that we can make sure that we
have the Amendments all back from OLS as
they as we would like them to be we need
a little bit more time to go through
these things I think this is a really
important piece of this legislation if
it's going to go forward so I would ask
the committee if
um if we can't do this now we could
attend to other amendments
um but I would like to have a chance to
go back to wallows and have them fix
this
with borrowing your motion then
yeah I'll withdraw my emotion
I'll withdraw my second okay and then um
if I could be recognized for emotional
sure representative land um thank you Mr
chairman um since I had already passed
it out it seems inappropriate time
um to uh move that we adopt amendment
1494h to send a bill to 63 FM
okay is there a second
representative Missouri seconds you wish
to speak to your motion uh yes thank you
Mr chairman uh
that
would you keep yours up for that
here it comes
um thank you so there's already existing
law within the the different programs
here if I can uh get to this section in
126a so I can tell you what this first
one falls under
126 double
in section 2 G which 2G is the
commissioner shall include an MCO
contracts with the state clinically and
actually sound incentives designed to
improve Care Quality and utilization and
to lower the total cost within the
Medicaid Managed Care Program this
commissioner shall also include in the
MCO contract provisions and obligation
for the MCO to include provider
alignment assistance to leverage and so
initial areas to improve Care Quality
and utilization and to lower the total
cost of care may include but are not
limited to and that's where we get to
the section A that currently says
reduction in poly Pharmacy resulting in
drug interaction harm this is a very
good opportunity for us to look at a
subset of people and see what
polypharmacy issues we have this would
be a chance to see who is on you know
statins and then other drugs that may or
may not be working towards the same goal
we may be looking at people that have
have multiple different
um different um psychiatric drugs and
also looking at Cross reactions across
other ones this is an issue that that
I've spoken with with colleagues about
and polypharmacy is is a clear and
present issue it increases the cost of
care it can decrease outcomes and this
would be responsible to include that in
the contracts with the mcos the second
one is another one based around
improving outcomes so in the RSA section
2 7
that chapter starts off
um actually that is the whole paragraph
there for any person determined to be
eligible and who is enrolled in the
program the MCO shall support an
individual to arrange a wellness visit
with his or her primary care and then it
has what the wellness visit includes if
the whole point of of having met having
this coverage available to people is to
get earlier treatment annual visits are
a very very good step towards that
because that's our first our chance to
do screening this is our chance to
intervene before somebody is showing up
in an emergency room if we're looking to
provide care earlier then annual visits
are important and this also adds the
language the annual Wellness visit
she'll check for poly Pharmacy
especially in the areas of Cardiology
and mental health to avoid dangerous
drug interactions and side effects
um
I recognize that providers have short
time periods to visit with people but if
we're looking and trying to reduce harm
and to improve the quality of care I
think that this is an important step
because that way the people who are
using these benefits will use them and
we won't be paying that we won't be
paying the rate for people who are not
interested to get an annual Wellness
visit yet we're still paying on an
annual basis for their care that they do
not receive so this is a bit of a give
and take
you go to the doctor we still have this
coverage and I think that that's
reasonable when we're trying to get into
preventative care and to stop Downstream
Harms
other discussion
yes representative
um more like a comment I I want to thank
representatively and you know for
bringing this amendment especially in
terms of uh Alias of Cardiology
Sciences uh evolving as a nation we are
spending billions on drugs like statins
but still
Cardiology problems remain high not
solved and often lead to death of
patience so it's important to study this
a popular Pharmacy and uh
actual uh
help or lack of it and side effects
so I'm very thankful for bringing us
this amendment
representative Palmer
so I completely thank you I completely
agree on the um the idea that
polypharmacy is a huge problem and
certainly a number of people I admit to
the hospital are in the hospital because
of it
um and I I the idea of an annual
wellness exam the only question I'd have
there is whether this is a particular
program whether that would be covered
under the program like it is under
Medicare but I the the idea is that's
that's great I think the reporting is
where I begin to have a problem if is it
would be great if we're going to do a
reporting thing to have it across
everywhere because if you have one
particular group that's being asked
you're being asked to report on as a
physician in your office keeping track
of that will would be uh sort of an
impossible nightmare
um so that would be so I'm I'm not
opposed to the idea I just don't know
how that would work because if if I see
you know 15 patients 20 patients in a
day I don't necessarily know what
insurance they have and I don't know
what
and this is this has been a real problem
about trying to figure out
which things to report on which things
are important and then having all of the
different payers agree and agencies
agree on which things and so I would
prefer to see that approached that way
as uh you know like
um the ACO in Vermont has struggled with
this but has come up with a thing where
they've sort of tried to reduce it into
one thing so you know if you're
practicing in Vermont you you sort of
know that you're going to be looking at
these 12 things rather than five things
from one insurance and seven from
another
other uh representative Murphy thank you
just a question clarification
um on line 18 the word support what is
the intent of support is that arrange
for a visit pay for a visit
um how do you define support there
um thank you that's in the existing
language and as yet one more example of
how the stat whole statute could use
some good close attention
but I agree it doesn't say whether it's
paid for it doesn't say if you just send
you a postcard to encourage it it
doesn't say if you do some skywriting
and put an ad on the TV so it's uh and
we've seen some uh different Outreach I
I could I could sew another El and
skydive in with a 70-foot banner behind
me but I'm a little out of practice
so I agree um that's a very vague term I
hear the landing is going to be quite
quite dangerous and representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chair
I do concur also with representative
Palmer uh polypharmacy is definitely an
issue particularly some of the elderly
that we run into
I would say that the appropriate place
to add reporting is not so much in the
statute here but also in the
commission's responsibilities and that's
probably the logical place to add it if
we want to add it number two as far as
the annual Wellness visit
um I totally agree with primary care but
under Medicare versus Medicaid
a wellness visit could be done by more
than Primary Care it could also be done
by a pharmacist because we do medication
therapy management constantly people who
are on poly Pharmacy are required to get
a visit by
the pharmacist if you will to check on
the polypharmacy I think it's also a
place that we could add
the role of the pharmacist in this
capacity to help in that to identify
potential patients because patients with
potential polypharmacy as well so for
those reasons I think number one is
it should be in the commission
responsibilities not in the statute per
se here I think number two we should be
thinking about adding other individuals
that have access to the patient record
to help identify polypharmacy as well
another discussion
representative lehan
um thank you Mr chairman
um I think with that um it probably
would make sense for me to go back I
guess is there support for me moving
that to a commission responsibility to
try and collect that information and
then to recruit pharmacists looking at
this having the annual Wellness knit
check for that quite honestly if that
became standard practice for everybody's
Wellness visit it would be a net
positive for Everybody's Health in the
state but if we had them getting that
information and included pharmacists are
there any other care providers or does
primary care provider cover everybody
but pharmacists that would do a wellness
visit
representative Merchant is there anybody
else I should include no because most of
the time we talk about Primary Care
includes the physician PA or nurse
practitioner maybe even an actual path
but it doesn't per se include the
pharmacist that's why in the Medicare
regulations it does include the
pharmacist in that language
I think thank you very much with that
I'll with I'll withdraw this amendment
so that I can send it back for
improvement
um would you withdraw your second
Okay so
that Amendment we will wait to hear more
about I guess
yep you're planning to bring that
forward next next week
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman I have another
amendment here uh this amendment is 1489
H and I move that we pass it
okay is there a second
I representative Plaza seconds
you wish to speak to your motion
yes thank you so this amendment that's
going around
um would add in section two of that RSA
126 AAA under Roman 2 subsection a
it's going to add a fourth section to
this there are some requirements under
this under that part of the statute
um to the extent Allowed by federal law
the individual shall so they provide
necessary information for financial
eligibility they inform the department
of changes in their eligibility and at
the time of enrollment they acknowledge
that the program is subject to
cancellation upon notice and
um we going back to what we were just
discussing
um
the mcos get a capitation rate for as
many people are on the rolls so we are
paying for as many people are on the
rolls whether they utilize the care or
not and
um so it would make sense that we would
periodically go through those roles and
find out if there are anyone who is not
utilizing the program and if they're not
utilizing it well then they probably
don't need to be a part of it and that
don't need the benefits and should be
taken off the roles and that would be a
responsible way to to operate so section
four says at the time of enrollment they
shall acknowledge that an
underutilization of benefits shall
result in the termination of benefits
upon annual re-verification and
re-enrollment a minimum utilization of
benefits for the purposes of this
section shall be defined as one annual
physical examination with a licensed
primary care provider within one year
from the date of enrollment or annual
re-enrollment
yeah I'll take any questions
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair
so
representative Cushman
I hear the concern about
underutilization and paying for benefits
that are not being utilized
I do consider myself on the other side
of the coin I'll be encouraging people
to over utilize to the to prevent the
underutilization so therefore we're
trying to in some ways have unintended
consequence where over utilization may
be triggered as an unintended
consequence to try to figure out how to
tackle underutilization
thank you for the question well there's
no there's no definition of over
utilization here it's just under
utilization which is a very very low bar
just says that you have to see your
primary care provider at least once a
year
beyond that that's appropriate that's an
appropriate level of utilization and if
you go to your primary care provider and
they find something and you need to
utilize further Services that's what the
program is for
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman I I will vote
against this amendment
um
I think people's lives are very
complicated I think
[Music]
um
people who are
have limited resources their lives tend
to be more complicated and
um in general if people are not
utilizing care
um then there's no payment for services
I understand that there would be a
payment for capitation for the you know
managed care I have no idea what that
payment is what the difference would be
to the state for one person
or 10 people who were taken off the
roles because of underutilization but I
think people's lives tend to be very
complicated and
um people I know I don't go to the
doctor when I don't have to and I don't
go to the doctor when I'm feeling well
and you know then something of you know
great significance could come up and I'm
really appreciative of having care
available and I think that that's what
we're providing for people to have care
available so I will vote against this
amendment
uh representative Murphy and then
representative King thank you I also
would
vote against the amendment in in park
Prince will be because I I think that
legislating
um uh Health Care in the practice of
Health Care is probably not our purview
um there are many people on Medicaid
that are in their 20s and 30s they're in
excellent health and you know they've
got jobs to keep and you know they may
not be able to go they don't feel bad
they don't
if you were to query everybody around
the table I'd ask how many times did you
see your primary care when you were in
your 20s and 30s I would say that was
not very often but you want to have the
health care available for them if they
do need it I'm also concerned with that
provision would overburden the primary
care provider that they would be seeing
a patient for an unnecessary unneeded
visit and when other people need to come
in and be seen lastly I would say that
primary care has a very broad definition
and it's not just your general
practitioner it also could be included
you're a pediatrician it includes your
OB GYN so I think that definition is
just a bit too lacks without any
specific definition so I would oppose
this amendment representative okay thank
you Mr chair I just want to thank
representative Cushman for the intent
but I would like to pair it with my
previous three Representatives
colleagues have said I agree with them
thank you
other discussion representative Cushman
did you sure
um well I just want to say that that
point that's being made is contrary to
the spirit of this entire program
especially since we that part of the
mcos
um
their goals is so that everyone gets
primary care and it's been stated
numerous times by our lobbyists and
members of the public who came to
testify that you know Primary Care is an
essential essential piece of this
because it's going to reduce
uncompensated care in hospitals later
which was another goal of the program
um and
um it's just it's starkly in contrast to
that if that's the goal then we should
be making sure that people are actually
attaining that and actually the mco's
incentivize
patients to go and have their visits
with their PCP they actually give them a
little benefit card that they can get
money on and they get money for going to
their primary care doctor
um so
I think that's a stark contrast with the
spirit of the program but I'll leave
that there representative Leon
uh thank you Mr chairman
um I I too am a little bit confused it
seems that they're sort of two thrusts
to this program there's the primary care
provision making sure that people get
appropriate Primary Care to prevent
um significant negative outcomes later
and then there's this idea of
catastrophic care you're talking about
the uncompensated care you're talking
about
um somebody who pressures their
parachute into the ground and breaks a
femur that sort of thing that they that
they otherwise may not have had care but
they're having this so Primary Care
avoids all but those accidents that it
helps to intervene earlier for all
except those actual physical accidents
so that we can reduce the overall cost
of care and it was my understanding that
that is the main part of this because
looking to the whole system if we're
looking at the uncompensated care for
accidents
um
other expensive end-stage healthcare
costs I'm almost wondering if then it
becomes less expensive for us as a state
to have a fund to pay for this
uncompensated care especially because
right now we're paying 50 million
dollars in state money with 450 million
in in federal match in order to cover
about 100 million in uncompensated care
so if our thrust isn't actually primary
care and getting that early care then
then I'm starting to wonder especially
if we don't have um a guarantee that the
program would end if the the federal
government backs off on their
contribution rate you know are we going
to end up being in a better position
financially being tied to this program
versus just being ready as as a body to
say here's our uncompensated care fund
here are the people that have have
reached that catastrophic issue and
we'll cover that if we're not willing to
incentivize Primary Care in order to
intervene earlier so I I'm just having a
hard time wrapping my head around these
two competing interests and why there
would be conflict with this amendment
representative Palmer and then remember
oh okay start new can finish thank you
so one issue I have with this is
um that
um where in the previous thing we were
talking about supporting uh Wellness
visits and
um you know it's great to start off that
way but I don't think any other
insurance company requires you to keep
to go every year to maintain the
insurance or certainly my employer
didn't require that of me the other
thing is that for most people under the
age of 50 or so well even people over
that an annual visit is no longer part
of the recommended scheme for um anybody
so if you look at the
um you know American college Physicians
recommendations American College of
family physicians they have specific
recommendations on screening over time
but it doesn't include an annual
physical and so to require that of of
this particular group doesn't make sense
to me encouraging them to get that
annual wellness check yes but but
requiring it as a condition of remaining
insured is a different thing
particularly when it's not recommended
medical care anymore
representative Nagel did you you said
all the smart stuff I was gonna say but
I'm I remember getting a beautiful chart
of what the screening Wellness
recommendations were and as you said my
age group they don't recommend an annual
physical at all the only reason I get
one is I'm not a med and he wants to see
me once a year to tell me I'm fine but
but the recommendations right now are
not annual
am I correct yeah
representative Shapiro you all set okay
anyone else any other discussion
representative Leon um thank you I have
a question then if um if these
screenings in these visits aren't
covered are we paying for that in the
MCO contracts to have these annual
visits if they're against guidelines
so that's that covered or not I mean I
as I said before encouraging people
particularly on enrolling in the in the
program if especially if they haven't
had health care
encouraging them and paying for an
initial visit to establish whether they
have any problems makes a great deal of
sense because that's where you can then
prevent you know you find that this
person is diabetic great now you've
probably saved a ton of grief and money
um but just but but sort of arbitrarily
having every year just for the to say in
the program doesn't isn't going to
contribute to health it's just it's just
sort of a it becomes just a hoop to jump
through which
um would end up
with its own set of issues
representative Cushman I just have a
question for representative Palmer
um
I I know you're
um you're calling it a hoop to jump
through but this is taxpayer funded this
is a entitlement program that's funded
by tax dollars I think that there should
be some baseline accountability
um and you know would you agree that we
should have some checks on this
so
thank you for the question
um
the simple answer is I guess I haven't
thought about this enough to really give
a thorough answer probably if you'd said
um if if this were you know people will
be required to have an initial visit
within a period of time for wellness
then you've sort of accomplished what I
said which is you see whether this
person has sort of hidden high blood
pressure diabetes all of those things
that we should screen for but you're not
then requiring them to come back every
year if they were completely healthy and
are 32 years old
and you're also not going to take away
the insurance that they may need if they
have an injury
um
just because
okay so a diff sorry so like a different
iteration of this idea though you might
support like if it if it was within the
first year they they need at least one
visit with a primary care physician in
the in the only other caveat getting
back to what representative Murphy said
is these people may have a hard time
getting that visit and so you'd have to
allow some kind of leeway where you're
you know like
they've tried nine times and they
finally have an appointment for
September of next year but at least
they're they're making the effort okay
thank you representative Merchant
following up on representative Palmer's
I do agree that probably when they first
come into the program sometimes when
they first come in the program they may
not have had health care for a period of
time
I checked in at that point to sort of
help guide the primary care person to
look at a screening if there's nothing
found then I would say at that point
it's probably up to the patient to
develop symptoms of something to go back
to the primary care doctor however on
the other hand if they do find diabetes
or something of that nature they
probably should be going to the primary
care doc at least once a year so it's
more of a step process where the first
time if you haven't been to a primary
care doc because you didn't have any
insurance you got a Medicare expansion
you know have the coverage
therefore you go see the primary care
doc I think at that initial visit is for
them to take the time to screen the
patient to find out there's something
that needs to be followed on a routine
basis
representative Nagel
um this is going to be an incredibly
cynical statement but I mean going back
I missed the whole basis of
patient-centered care every patient's
unique every patient's different we do
have routine protocols for everybody but
they're not annual um you have that
initial visit you make your decisions
for that individual patient and thank
you that's the way we did things 30
years ago
before everybody started telling us what
to do when it worked just fine and I
mean that's the way the system should
work
representative Murphy thank you yeah and
I would just reiterate that I would not
be opposed I don't like the idea of
legislating medical care but on the
other hand to enter into this program
with the recommendation or requirement
of having a visit within the first uh 12
to 16 months so that they get in there
it's not just checking their blood
pressure and seeing if they have high
blood sugar they would also do an exam
you know a family history exam so if you
have a history of colon cancer you may
recommend that they get their
colonoscopy sooner or you have a history
of prostate cancer you get it done
Syrian piece whatever it is breast
cancer whatever it is so you take it's
not just the blood work it's not the
blood pressure it's also the family
history but I I fully support Wellness
exams and I think that
um though I'm hesitant in a time to
require a visit because I don't want to
clutter up offices I don't think it
would be inappropriate to strongly
recommend in some language that they see
somebody initially for their care in
evaluation
representative Shapiro
I think I I think I understand the
philosophically what this amendment is
trying to get at which is that um
is that patients should have some skin
in the game and there should be
accountability it's a public program
that uses taxpayer dollars and therefore
there should be some accountability on
the part of patience or recipients
um so I understand philosophically I I
think where this comes from
but I don't understand what I don't get
is is there a specific problem that's
borne out by data that says this is
something we have to fix I mean do we
know that people are not are under
utilizing care or not signing up with a
primary care service
so is there is there data that points to
a specific problem that we're trying to
fix with this amendment
because other otherwise it feels to me
like it's just punitive that it's just
um and really
um
I am concerned about the Dignity of the
patients also that we not be
micromanaging what they do and what they
don't do unless there's a specific
problem that we're trying to remedy
thank you for the question respectfully
the specific problem is wasteful
spending I mean that affects the entire
state if we have people on the rolls for
this program that never utilize it and
really don't care to utilize it why do
we pay the mcos you know per person
who's on the rolls it just it's not a
responsible way to do business and in
New Hampshire we tend to be responsible
with taxpayer money and entitlement
programs so I think putting a little
your your you hit the nail on the head
that this is a from a matter of it's a
matter of principle in governing if we
are to offer programs there needs to be
a little bit of accountability and I
think that this entire program because
it's mostly the the way that the federal
government has designed it
um and our community engagement aspect
of it is not enforceable there is there
is little accountability in it so I
would just like to see that we're making
sure that it's being utilized and if
it's not being utilized by by some mem
some members who are on the rolls that
they they should be removed and they
should just agree to that when they
apply for it
follow-up follow-up representative
I I'll address this to you but
representative Cushman but if anybody
might um know do we have any data on how
many people do not go to their Primary
Care
um provider or
what percentage of people do not utilize
the program in a way that
we may think is the right way to utilize
it
it's a good question I don't think I
don't know that we do but we probably
should
representative Palmer
so I I mean this is getting into the
weeds and maybe somebody from HHS can
answer this but I mean we have a Managed
Care Organization running these programs
and I think that the rationale is
probably that the the numbers in New
Hampshire are too small to make it
um what's the word that insurance
companies use
um the the bottom line is that if we do
if we have an MCO that it's going to
cost the state a fixed amount per number
of patients and we don't have to worry
that seven of them end up needing bone
marrow transplants and that the program
gets blown out of the water
um and so on the one hand you know
you're concerned about having people who
were paying so much per month to be in
the program is a problem but we're doing
it that way because overall we we think
or whoever set this program up thinks
that that's going to a save money in the
long term and but B prevent you know big
Financial spikes that would be a real
problem and I don't know if there was a
choice whether New Hampshire chose to go
the MCO route in you know California
they're they're big enough to
self-insure so they're doing it on a
capital you know on a regular basis
uh representative Nagel thank you
that this has been a very interesting
discussion thanks for bringing it up um
I would probably be willing to answer
your question earlier representative
Cushman I think I would be
willing to support a statement that say
within a certain time frame of either
before or after becoming enrolled that
you were expected to see your doctor and
then the doctor and you create a
strategy for long-term management of
problems you do where you don't have a
lot of these patients already have a
relationship with the primary so I would
include you know prior experience in
that whatever definition you chose to
make but I think given the circumstances
as you've raised them I think that makes
sense
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you colleagues for
this great discussion
um it seems it seems like this whole
idea of an annual visit may not be
appropriate but I'm curious about
whether
um having a care plan that's agreed upon
by that primary care provider and the
patient would make sense that way if you
had a condition that required more
frequent monitoring there would be that
incentive to actually come and show up
for your appointments but if you were
healthy as a horse and they said we'll
see you in another five years if you're
still on this program or even if not
I'll see you in five years unless you
have a problem that if there was an
agreed upon care plan that may be
something that we could help
um keep people too because
I know there's a lot of people that
don't necessarily like going to the
doctor and I know there's a lot of
people whose schedules fill up with
everything that is not the necessary and
required
um it's really easy to put your health
on the back burner especially if you're
a parent with small kids but if you do
that for too long there might be a fire
on that stove and if if we can figure
out if we can have a care plan that's
agreed upon by the primary care and the
patient about how frequently they would
come in that could be negotiated and be
considered something that would be
reasonable obviously it could be fleshed
out in rules but that might be some way
to
sort of get some better buy-in between
both the patient and the physician about
how frequently they should come in and
if we're paying a capitated rate for
people to come in and get care I think
that that would show a longer term
reduction in the cost of care when you
know that you have people who are
actually showing up to their
appointments because I do know from the
device World
um and looking with the hospitals at
that time people who don't follow up on
their treatments can often end up with
um unexpected well
often end up I would call it unexpected
but unfortunately when you look at the
Actuarial tables it's actually it's an
expected outcome just not for everybody
so I'm curious what people would think
about a care plan for visits as opposed
to an annual recommendation because that
could allow those who are both more
um
more medically complex and those who are
a lot less medically complex both to get
a better idea of the playing field and
figure out how to collaborate going
forward
representative Merchant
I want to say thank you groups of Leon
for what you're bringing forth and also
the Cushman for the discussion
place any of these requirements on the
employer-sponsored healthcare
is a free market they basically at that
point in time negotiate
plan with the insurance companies based
upon what they decide that they want to
cover and what they do so I don't know
why we're getting into the micromanaging
of trying to figure out what to do with
Granite State Advantage with the MCO
contract I think I'll go back to I said
before a lot of this belongs in the
commission not here in this legislative
body and let them bring the
recommendations back to us as policy
makers to make a change in the policy if
we need to but again I go back
when we have commercial insurance
companies out there we don't try to
micromanage them either so why are we
trying to do it here today
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um I I reject the um the comparison
between a employer who's paying for
health care for his employees and that's
their choice
um
to taxpayers a taxpayer-funded health
care plan
taxpayers don't have a choice they pay
their taxes it comes out of of you know
their paycheck from the federal
government and
you know from their business Enterprise
tax or or what have you in the state but
you know it's it's completely different
we we have a vested interest in ensuring
that this program is responsibly run
that there are checks and balances for
financial
responsibility and enrollee
accountability
that's completely different from an
employer sponsored private insurance
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and respectfully
I'd like to weigh in on that as well as
the legislators we are the ones
entrusted with figuring out where to put
the state's dollars employers who are
buying employers sponsored um health
insurance have the opportunity to make
make changes and make choices within
their insurance as the market
standardizes with more and more people
on standardized care like Medicaid
Medicaid expansion and um and some of
the other programs that simply follow
along there's less and less choice for
those employer-sponsored plans as well
but as as the stewards of taxpayer money
it is our job respectfully to put out
some of those requirements for those MCO
contracts and that's specifically why
this program needs to be reauthorized
from time to time as opposed to approved
in perpetuity
for the discussion
all right there's no other discussion
I'll ask at the Clark call the wall
motion is ought to pass on Amendment
1489 H2S space 263.
foreign
yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofault yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel no
representative pelosov yes
representative Cannon
no
representative Wallner no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas no
representative yeah
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
representative Lloyd no
and representative McDonald yes
8 to 12 bills motion fails eight to
twelve
okay
um I don't know how long the next
discussion is going to take one of you
has indicated at least one of you has
indicated they need to leave it three
so um I'm I'm here for however long but
obviously it's an executive session so
um representative land
thank you I think that this one will be
a little shorter so I don't know if I
could introduce this amendment true well
give it a whirl I move that we adopted
1629 each I will pass that around and
this one is about the acceptability of
waivers
um sorry let me count these
I know there's some in this stuff
somewhere else let's send these along
this way
sorry I should have put the box on the
table I was trying not to scare anybody
with my file folders but it would have
been a lot cleaner that way
okay
I may have sent too many Along on that
side
oh here we go
any chance thank you
okay I could pass these along that way I
found the rest of the stack I apologize
okay that's a single-sided so there's
two pages
to 1629 H leading amended analysis and
then the main Amendment no
yourself
there was one that came out not
double-sided because the page is stuck
together
um and I don't think I successfully
removed that from the stack so I
apologize
um if you got just the amended analysis
you can probably trash that the the main
part of the bill is the section amending
section inserting section eight
um into the statute in 126 double A
um
sorry yes inserting this um so what it
says doing is a bending part of the
underlying bill that we are looking to
potentially reaffirm in perpetuity uh in
the statute right now it gives rule
making authority to the commissioner
but I'd like to know who in this
committee knows how to define the terms
unreasonably inconsistent
I'm sorry
representative seconds got it sorry
thank you thank you I want to thank the
clerk for pointing that out to me thank
you go ahead representative land sorry
to interrupt uh definitely I think we
all need some more coffee soon
uh so I was also digging through all the
roles associated with this program
um
there's more issues there within the
rules and them going outside of the the
legislative prescription but right now
it says that the rules should be
consistent with the terms and conditions
of any waiver issued by the centers for
Medicare and Medicaid services for the
program it's provided that any waiver
issued is not unreasonably inconsistent
with the provisions of this chapter and
then it gives some conditions
unreasonably inconsistent is
it's something that I can't quite Define
I'm not sure if anybody else can but um
I think that that just gives too much
Authority that any waiver that comes
through amended would then go into our
rules and then have the force of law so
in order to address that and address the
fact that if this is adopted permanently
we would be putting into our rules
whatever waivers come down from the
federal government and giving the force
of our law to those waivers it should
not be in conflict with any of this
enabling legislation so that's why I
have this amendment here in order to
make sure that any waivers that we
accept by putting them into our rules
are not in conflict with our enabling
law
discussion
wow yes it is going to be shorter
okay if there's no discussion I'll ask
the clerk to follow all
motion is ought to pass on Amendment
1629 h
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative Boyd yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
representative peloso yes
representative Cannon no
representative
Wallner no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas no
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
representative Lloyd no
and representative McDonald yes
10 to 10 motion fails
next week
um
looks like you have more amendments are
they short as short as this sir it's
hard to tell
I mean honestly
yes there's another short one here I
guess I honestly thought there'd be some
discussion if there was dissent to that
Amendment
um would you if you want to offer
another one
wow
so it's
um I move that we
I move ought to pass on Amendment 2023
1620h to Senate bill 263. is there a
second
representative Leon seconds
thank you so this amendment
passing around
okay
um is very simple
um so as we were talking about the
community engagement requirement that's
the the work requirement
um currently it's not enforced and
um
I was told that there is a chance that
the federal government may be changing
their approval of these work
requirements and Georgia now has one in
place
um so ours got kind of kicked around the
courts and then
um our request for approval was
withdrawn so we could request approval
of this again and I think that it is our
duty to do so to apply for the center
for Medicare and Medicaid services to
approve our community engagement
requirements under this section
so this just directs the commissioner
within six months of the enactment of
um SB 263
to submit that request to the federal
government
thank you discussion
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman um I think this is absolutely
critical our current statute 126 double
A has plenty of requests for waivers and
it's important to put that request in so
that it is the will of the legislature
um
and so I support this amendment
another discussion
representative Shapiro I'm going to vote
against this amendment
um
and um
it is true that this was
um
ruled invalid by a federal court and
what the federal court said was that
providing Medicare to the needy is
Medicaid's core objective and the waiver
failed to adequately consider the work
requirements effect on Medicaid coverage
in other words that
um
the core principle of Medicaid is to
provide medical coverage not to provide
work Readiness or character building so
that was the spirit of the Court
decision which I agree with
um so
whether it whether
things
have changed enough so that uh a waiver
such as this would be reconsidered by
the federal government I don't know but
in any case I'm against having this kind
of work requirement so I'm going to vote
no on this
another discussion
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman um so
um I I got the history for of this from
um Mr Robert Berry from the Department
um and he did mention to me that the U.S
House of Representatives is considering
legislation that would Implement some
form of community engagement
requirements for
um for CMS and that
um that it very well may be possible
that ours would be approved so I think
now while we have this bill in front of
us and while the federal government
um you know is in their
negotiations
um we there's nothing to lose by having
this request submitted we you know we
just need to seek this waiver if it's
going to be available and you know it's
in our statute already
so you know
the the legislature has spoken that it
does this work requirement should be in
place we want there to be a work
requirement if this program is to be
um in New Hampshire this is what makes
this
part of what makes this
um a New Hampshire specific program
otherwise you know
we're just doing whatever the federal
government
prescribes so I think if there's an
opportunity for us to implement it that
it's you know our responsibility to try
to
other discussion
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I think this once again
illustrates how a large section of the
statute in 126 double A is not in effect
because it's about the work requirements
and the community engagement that is not
enforceable so once again this is why we
need to have a sunset on this and why we
need to come back to this
of the discussion
there's no other discussion I'll ask the
clue I'm sorry representative Palmer did
you I'm sorry hey
you just turned it off turned it off
sorry thank you I I was just reading and
my concern would be this
um so Georgia has just managed to get
this
past through their the court down there
um but the judge there ruled it was
substantially different from the case in
Kentucky Arkansas and New Hampshire so
since and and the reason I guess is
because Georgia had just enacted their
Medicaid expansion expansion we already
have it so we we along with Kentucky and
Arkansas are con it's considered a
reduction in benefits by doing this and
so the court said that's that's a
problem but what Georgia did was they
did it initially so they were expanding
their services so I'm not a lawyer but
my concern would be if we try to push
this in New Hampshire has to go to court
how much is that going to cost and are
we going to just run up against a brick
wall again
representative Cushman thank you
um well it doesn't say that we have to
carry it to you know push it through the
courts it just says that they have to
submit an or a request for approval of
the of the waiver I mean of the
community engagement
so and as we're by that time within six
months from now legislation may have
gone through on the federal level that
permits that to be
operable
other discussion representative Palazzo
I will support this amendment I think it
reinforces us the intent
of the uh underlying
um
existing legislation and it's very
important uh to stay in
uh with that intent because even though
we had we had many testimonies that many
participants
of this uh indicator expansion are
uh working and being
engaged we don't know what economic
situation would be in one year or in two
years and what new participants of this
Medicaid
expansion will be and in what
circumstances so I think it's important
to uh
uh ask for this approval so I will
support this amendment
thank you representative Nagel
I'm gonna admit my total naivety but um
two questions one is where do I find the
community engagement requirement
and secondly we're just submitting a
request to CMS who could easily just say
no
am I correct about that and number
number one where do I find what the
requirement actually is most of my
Medicaid expansion patients actually
have a job so I assume that would
qualify them
under
uh representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman um the work
requirements are in 126 double a
um it is for 100 hours a month based off
of the 25 hour work work week
um the
within within the language it includes
um work in the private sector it
includes a number of different things
and so it's very broad reaching even
volunteering with a non-profit satisfies
that watching your children or
babysitting others satisfies that work
requirement it is very Broad and it
provides ample opportunity
there are also a lot yes
and also our committee researcher has
said that she could provide some more
information on work requirements for us
as well for next week if that would be
helpful I can find where the language is
on these
it's 126.
a a colon 2.
and then also as as far as that goes
um the there's supposed to be an
opportunity to cure if you're short on
the hours and this also is another area
that needs to be addressed legislatively
the administrative rules with no
grounding and statutes said that nobody
can be asked to work more than 100 hours
even if they're making up for a loss in
the previous month so as long as
eventually you put in a month with 100
hours you're considered in compliance
and given that if you have basically a
doctor's note saying that you have a
reason why you aren't able to
participate that there's
um
if there's a storm that keeps you from
attending that you get waived hour for
hour there's a lot of trade-offs as well
um and you know honestly as a mom I'm a
little offended that the entire
pregnancy period is considered a
disability
um I I think that uh being able to
continue on with life and work during
your pregnancy makes sense and the
doctor's note during your pregnancy or
any other time saying that you're not
able to work I think should be
sufficient for anybody except that last
week when you're saying oh my goodness
it's time
um sorry I'm getting into another one
that I have here I apologize for
diverting my attention but we we have a
very very generous program that allows
for a lot of different things including
on-the-job training education
and participation in substance use
disorder treatment recovery activities
and or mental health treatment
representative Shapiro
um I would agree with representative
Leon that there's generous opportunities
to be accepted if you have a problem
fulfilling the work requirement I
wouldn't say it's very generous on the
other hand because I it was the most
it was the most hours required of any
waiver given in throughout the country
so the the requirements were the most
extreme in the country
um when when we did get that waiver
um also I think that um in in regards to
the discussion about
um maybe there being changes in federal
legislation that would allow
these kinds of waivers that has been
discussed in the news recently and was
included in the house the federal house
legislation that passed recently
regarding the debt limit but I don't
think that anybody really expects that
that will become
um
you know it's got a lot of steps to go
before it comes law and it it doesn't
seem like it's going to that's gonna
happen at least in the way it was passed
in the in the House of Representatives
so it is it is being discussed on the
national level but it's far from being a
reality
of the discussion
say no other discussion
um so I'll ask the clerk to call the
wall the motion is ought to pass on
1620h amendment to Senate bill 263.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
Boyd yes representative Seth King yes
representative mazur yes representative
Nagel
representative peloso yes
representative Cannon
no
representative Wallner no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas
no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no representative
Palmer no
representative Lloyd no
representative McDonald yes
9 to 11 fails
and the amendment fails nine to eleven
okay at this point we might be pushing
our luck with those of you who need to
leave
um shortly I do have a couple of
announcements one I'll be sending out a
list of the
um retained bills that
um this just a number of us are
wondering about them and we also need to
uh consider how we're going to handle
those uh not and you know immediately
but obviously those need to be on our
radar screens and if we can start
thinking about what areas we might be
interested in working on those as as
time passes
also next week on the subcommittee on
um 240 is going to be meeting at 10 A.M
right and representative Merchant
representative Leon and representative
Weber uh prior to that they're going to
be meeting at 10 A.M
um so we're going to be meeting this
committee will be meeting at
um at 11 A.M right
um and that is all I have
oh yes it'll be on next Wednesday the
10th yes
Mr chairman did we want to discuss about
about the floor Amendment there well
um that wasn't really a noticed item for
us so I don't want to be accused of
doing a work session again but um what I
can do tomorrow is make an announcement
of having a brief executive session at
the on the floor I'm going to announce
that and then I guess that'll be Papa
notice because we'll all be there anyway
so
yes representative Merchant
I believe that is going to be
heard on the floor on May 11th is that
the case 238 yes uh yeah I've uh yes
could we make the discussion of 238 for
Amendment during the work session next
week
now notice it
if we discuss it next week
I don't know would that be enough time
to put it in the to discuss it on the 11
the next day
be a floor Amendment uh representative
Leon uh thank you my only one concern
with that would be making sure that we
could get it in time if everybody was
was favorable of the change in language
um I I don't expect that it will I think
we'll get an idea of whether or not it
takes us more time and would then need
to be announced and put in for a work
session on um next Wednesday if we're if
we don't have an easy agreement
um when we meet for five or five minutes
or so I guess at lunch
tomorrow at session that was my under my
thinking
if I heard it correctly I think it was
grab some bland we have to notice the
fact we're going to have a discussion
about it which is a work session
so I guess the questions of the chair is
do we have to notice it
so we can have the discussion on it next
week yeah work session has to be noticed
in the calendar
yeah uh Ms Dyer can you notice that for
us
a work session on that Amendment HP SB
238 yes and it will likely be a
different amendment number but a work
session on Senate Bill 238. if we're
able to to notice that since we have
already reported it would really be in a
like it's going to end up being a floor
Amendment
but something we're going to I mean is
that feasible
okay
okay great thank you
all right uh anything else come before
the committee before we adjourn
saying nothing thank you very much and
I'll see you next week actually I'll see
you tomorrow